It's just started.
Did you start a registry?
How dare you man?
I'm not tweeting it.
Hold on.
So people have to hear me tweet.
Here we go.
Good on twitter.
Yep.
Tapenade numbers
talking.
Go for it,
baby.
Saying come on and don't consider.
I don't know that song.
The twitter.
Yeah,
I forgot my phone at home.
Which later?
You forgot your phone.
I feel so fucking naked right now.
It's never just awful.
At least I just tracked it online so I'm
keeping an eye on it.
So it's kind of like looking at photos
of my family,
you know?
It's like,
it feels good that I know it's still
alive like,
you know,
like I see it on Google maps and still
alive listed.
If I just tweeted what are the odds that
Joe Rogan and Duncan trussell got so
higher now having an amazing
conversation without the podcasts
running.
It's true.
I'm going to tweet one.
Tweet that with 100 percent.
Let's just plow through this commercial
real quick so we can get started.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by.
I said pod cat high cat's podcast is
brought to you by [inaudible] dot net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and
enter in the code name Brogan.
You will get 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men.
Dunkin,
you'd go,
you're going to enjoy.
I got a new one for you.
Excellent.
What is it?
It's,
it's uh,
uh,
give it to you later.
Really.
Some girls,
but all or something.
Is it the Iron Lady?
Good.
Whoever it looks like a great little
butthole.
You're going to love it.
Yeah.
How do you know it's a girl's butthole?
While they say they modeled them after
the girls puzzling.
It looks like a butthole.
It's like they.
Yeah,
they do the vagina.
They do the butthole.
They,
they actually make a mold.
They're posting.
That's why a lot of these freaks.
Like these porn star chicks.
Yeah.
They have their own flashlights.
It's like molded after their own box.
So there's a professional pussy mold or
something looks on the outside like
exactly what their box looks like.
That's the weirdest jobs on teen back in
Boston.
I want to get inside a box.
You got to touch a box.
That's what dudes used to say a lot.
The worst description.
China,
it's the least geometric shape on the
planet is the last thing you want to
fuck is a box is that Boston was a mess
anyway.
Did they do that when you were young?
Was that box or.
No,
but I can remember.
I can remember getting like sick.
My mom was a psychologist that she like
gave me like a,
a sex book,
like when I was trying to learn about
sex and it was like lists of the,
of the slang for pussy and I remember
getting the box and it was like wracking
my already vague understanding of what a
policy wise because it's like I always
at anything like a box.
That's hilarious.
It's more like a bag than a box.
It's not like youtube either,
but that's what the flashlight is.
It's a tube.
Well,
it's a.
it's a,
it's.
I don't want to do a fucking puppet show
with flashlights.
That's taking a hand puppet show with
your hands.
You can make mount.
I was thinking about taking the many
flashlights you've given me and doing
some kind of like Shakespeare,
but how many do you have?
Well now there's only two.
Now.
One of them is totally to now.
One of them is,
well no one of them.
This is a gross story.
I don't going to tell her what is a
disgusting.
Sorry I didn't clean one out and I left
it sitting on top of the shower is a
growth story and I like so,
so I,
uh,
I can remember the smell.
It's the smell is what I imagine these
hives and starcraft smell like.
It's like this just disintegrated alien.
It's like the smell of it.
Like you know,
when the aliens,
when they go down into that fucking in
the very beginning,
when they go into the pit where there's
all the pods and the thing pops out and
lands in the guy's face.
It's in the very beginning of the movie
alien.
It's like a have seen it.
That's what an old flashlight smells
like when you open it.
It's this kind of alien,
pungent,
muscular,
primordial smell.
But I opened it up and men who was just
like black and dark is black ooze,
just kind of drips out of it.
And,
and,
and so I threw that one away.
Is it like,
seriously dissonant?
You'd have to disinfect that with so
many chemicals.
Have to worry about those chemicals
eventually burning the skin off your
deck.
Well,
yeah.
And,
and some unknown disease.
Leprosy.
That's where it gets born in the bottom
of the fleshlight from some sick fucks.
It never bothered to clean it.
You tried to fuck it twice.
That's the end of the world.
The,
the one,
the one flashlight and there'll be told
about on fucking big stone tablets
10,000
years from now,
we've traced it back to a flashlight and
there's only a few people survived.
Only liked from one particular area of
Ethiopia were able to handle it well.
What dead?
I mean a flashlight is truly a breeding
ground for bacteria if you consider it,
especially if you keep it in the balmy
atmosphere of your shower because you're
combining fucking.
You're combining so many bad elements
thing and he makes him with heat.
Sure.
And who knows what's in the water,
water supply DNA,
your true life precursors in there.
You could.
It could sprout a new life.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Why not?
Right?
Yeah,
mean we,
we,
we poo poo that.
But could you imagine if it was that
easy?
Can you imagine if your loads on their
own could make people just grow like
mushrooms or imagine.
I mean when we know that you have to
interact with a woman and make eggs,
you know,
crack eggs and make babies that way.
But imagine if that wasn't the case,
imagine if every time you came it made
people measure,
people came out of your Dick and there's
just people everywhere,
everywhere getting stepped on that
little ones,
never get to be adults.
We take it for granted that the process
is a and female
and that that's the only way to create
life.
I mean,
life is crazy enough as it is to think
they would,
could have been in some bizarre Gonzo
parallel universe that it's possible to
just create life with your Dick and
every time you come,
boom,
people,
a person can be a very overpopulated
university.
Imagine people screaming at you because
you're beating off you fuckhead.
What are y'all doing?
Piling on top of people everywhere and
then you kept someone beating off.
Will you fucking stop it?
They just make it.
People bought.
That's what people would do.
We wouldn't make so many people.
If that was the case,
there'd be so many people that the world
would cave in.
There would be no more written work.
You would have.
People would just eat the people in
front of them.
You run out of reach.
So yeah,
we'd be just eating each other,
meeting the people in front of him
jerking off and making more.
I mean,
at what point can overpopulation exist?
if there's no structure,
right?
If you took all the people in New York
City with no structures,
no buildings,
just piled them on top of each other.
You know how many.
How much room is there?
At what point in time could you a
fucking imagine?
How many people would it take to cover
the planet and just a complete map of
people.
It's just every time someone came,
a person was born.
How long was it?
Just looked like an octopus.
Oh my God.
Warming freaks.
No one would stop.
We wouldn't stop.
We would nonstop jerking off.
We would.
We'd have entire continents covered and
you'd come up with a good reason why
you're jerking off.
You'd rationalize like,
wow,
what the fuck?
I go,
dude,
a new.
The government would get involved though
and make you so you can't come.
Like they would start neutering.
You would be the government.
They'd be swarms of people.
It'd be unmanageable.
There'd be no government.
No,
no buildings.
The blog,
we would have never even built
buildings.
If it was possible,
we would have ever figured out anything.
If that was how you could come and make
a person.
It'd be like grass.
It'd be like grass at.
Yeah.
We'd be everywhere.
Kudzu.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot net.
Click on the link for the flashlight,
the codename Rogan,
and you get 15 percent off the ruin sex
toy for men,
but best commercial ever.
Those are the best one we ever did.
People complain about those.
I'm like,
come on,
we're free balling.
We're just having fun.
Let us just do this little business
thing.
We're also brought to you by.
Wait,
wait,
and if you don't want to buy a
flashlight,
don't buy it.
Just make your own eye.
How can you do that?
Easily?
Melons,
melons,
fruits,
but did not going to be as good as the
flush if you're looking to master,
but it's a fucking solid tool.
There's probably some shit you can do
with Jello and gumby and will be as good
as the flashlight.
They got it.
They got it down.
Whatever that polymer is,
they used to make the vagina.
It's fucking outstanding.
They spent a long time.
Jumps up.
Yeah,
they did.
They have a great product.
There's how many people are embarrassed
about the fact that like to masturbate.
How many uncomfortable flashlights that
guy fuck before he
came upon this.
Could you imagine that?
Poor Weirdo.
This one's made out of rock,
eh?
He didn't touch them with fingers first.
You don't want to just shove your Dick
Right into this new retro model.
You don't let it do that if you don't
want to just use the,
they must have tested them out to
animals.
They use the animal or solving.
Ultimately the dude had to fuck like a
lot of different
substances in order to create that
perfect vagina.
I mean,
how do you describe that?
If you're trying to make it,
you know,
and you bring it to a factory.
This is what I'm looking for.
Something like,
fuck,
I'd like to see that moment when he
found it.
He said,
yeah,
I came like five times that last line.
Uh,
well,
yeah,
what a weird,
a weird thing to invent.
But he did an awesome job.
However,
the process was we're making light of
it.
He needs to write about the pilot came
about.
That's an interesting thing now.
No.
Well I think uh,
do to invented it.
His,
um,
his uh,
his wife was pregnant when he invented
it and he couldn't have sex.
So they figured out.
He gives resourceful fella.
See that?
Yeah.
That's what you need,
man.
If you want to invent something good,
you've got to be pushed.
You got to be pushed,
pushed in a corner.
Yeah,
and then you go for the box stuck.
You're writing a box.
Worse description.
Description started with a guy.
His wife had a deformed pussy was
brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com,
o n n I t bakers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement.
A shroom tech immune.
So you use the shroom tech immune
like I'm a fucking shell because I'm
agreeing to everything here,
but I've used these things.
These shroom tech.
Yeah.
When I'm starting to get sick,
I eat it and I get better at this stuff.
Real.
I'm sorry.
This stuff really works.
It sure is great for just to keep your
immune system strong.
Apparently the way it works is there's
something in it that makes your body
think that it's like a disease,
like,
yeah,
whatever.
If there's an intruder,
so your immune system fires up for a
fight that never takes place.
It's pretty fucking sporty thing if it
works like that.
Um,
there's also an Alpha brain,
excuse me,
shroom tech sport,
which is the quadriceps mushroom,
a sports endurance supplement.
And this is only for people who are
really into working out.
If you're not in Oregon out,
don't fuck with it.
Brian doesn't.
Nah,
I don't need it.
But if you're in Fitbit,
my fitbit let's say,
is that like last three days?
It is for people that don't know what
you're talking about.
It's his little thing you snap on you
and it counts your steps.
And it also like,
I like every time you do go up and
downstairs it measures out what that
would be in distance.
It just pretty much tracks everything
you do physically and then at night you
it and it tells you how long you sleep,
how many times do you wake up in the
middle of the night and in it.
Then it graphs it on this nice page on
their website and then you start having
like a facebook page of what your fitbit
is.
It's really weird.
It's like,
it's like twitter weird.
Like we have these stats and then like,
like right now my only friends,
Bert Kreischer and,
and you know,
I look at his and he's like,
like kicks ass.
And then my shit's like,
you know,
barely registering on the graph and my
battery light's like seven times longer
than birch.
That's like a new way to stalk people.
I mean,
you could be their exercise buddy.
Yeah.
Get a,
a constant readout.
I bet the readouts.
Being sensitive government also.
That's going to be the thing,
man.
You're going to have to put your
information out there so people know
where your heart rate is at every
moment.
I have this thing that tweets here.
Wait,
they have a scale that tweets your way
so that it's not supposed to keep you
motivated to lose weight.
Well eventually it's going to be more
than that.
If you have something on tweets it every
time you get on it so you can't even
stop it.
So yeah,
that's it.
So you get onto this really brutal on.
You're gaining weight and you start.
It was brutal.
But we are saying about the invention of
the flashlight.
If you weren't real change to happen,
change comes from fucking suffering.
Change comes from being in a place that
you don't want to be.
I mean,
you could do it other ways,
but generally it comes from getting
backed into a corner.
Yeah,
you gotta you gotta straighten up.
You get your shit together.
You got to fight back.
That's why people get enthusiastic about
things and start companies and get a big
burst of enthusiasm.
I could never murder somebody while
wearing a fitbit.
I just realized why because they will
know.
They will be able to see graph because
it shows you when you're extremely
working out and it has like red grabs
and stuffed up thinking about murdering
people.
Or I could put it on somebody that,
that,
you know,
isn't like sleeping like I could put on
my mom and then go out and in the middle
of the night and murder people that come
back and take off.
My Mom's not going to accept your fit
bit and that they could use that as
evidence.
I would imagine.
Well,
there could also use it as evidence that
your resting heart rate went from 70 to
82 or whatever.
Open person.
So I did a review on [inaudible] dot TV
fitbit.
You're really into it.
Uh,
uh,
and it's kind of,
I can see what it's like when I started
using twitter for the first time.
There's something there.
There's some kind of weird.
This is the next step,
right?
This is the next piece of connectivity.
This is turning your body into an x box
when it comes to like fitness,
you know,
it's fit.
That's fucking bad ass man.
Wow.
That's kind of interesting.
Yeah.
And of course you're going to be like
that.
Have the most friends of fitbit rural
because you're going to be working out
so extreme and everyone that would be
like,
you're,
you're not like instead of Dane Cook
having 5 million friends on twitter that
you would have the most extreme.
You have the most like red graph,
like you worked out the hardest or a lot
of dudes beating off to my account.
Could be that too.
And the person that sleeps,
that's the person that sleeps the best.
Would it be like some kind of weird
wizard of
Fitbit road?
We should have talked about this on the
let's just get this commercial over with
on a day you just go to [inaudible] dot
com.
I'm tired of talking about this stuff.
Here's how I feel about it.
It's we can't make this any nicer.
And by the way,
we had to change a rule because some
people are cons.
We used to say that if you buy something
and you don't like it,
you could send it back and you don't
even have to send it back.
We'll give you 100 percent money back
guarantee.
But people were buying like 10 bottles
and then they would.
They would take like three of them will
go,
yeah,
I'm not really into this.
And so then they would sell the rest on
Ebay so they would get their refund and
then they would sell on Ebay.
Unbelievable people such twats it will
find a hole that was a good idea,
but it wasn't a good idea to take
advantage of our hospitality.
So now it's only the first 30 pills and
you should be able to figure out within
30 pills.
I mean,
you know,
it's a lot of people say like,
if you could you,
can you really.
How much can you tell the difference
between when you're eating multivitamins
and when you're not?
Any multivitamins?
I can tell.
I can tell there's this subtle thing.
It's a,
but I'm really in tune with my shit.
I eat healthy.
I work out a lot.
I take supplements.
I know like what gets me and what
doesn't.
But there's some people,
man that don't know you can,
you can give them things and they're not
sure.
Is this my multivitamin?
Wharton was in watching,
you know,
they're not,
they don't feel they're,
but they're not in tune with their body
so much.
You know,
and I mean if you're not really
athletic,
if you don't push your body to extremes
and you don't eat healthy and clean,
I think a lot of people,
they.
There's a missing amount of
communication.
There's not an in intimacy with your
body.
Well,
they,
what?
I think when you're feeling bad,
you kind of get good at numbing it out
or ignoring it.
So they're,
they've kind of liked.
They've shut down their ability to like
feel if you really honestly appraise
their health because like if you're out
of shape and you're fucking smoking all
the time and you're drinking all the
time,
I speak from experience.
If you get into like a Jag of living
like that,
after a certain amount of time,
you just start tuning out the weird
pains in your body.
You just started ignoring it because you
don't want to.
You don't because it's just the truth
and the truth is you can't constantly
fucking eat like shit and smoke and
drink and that ended up with you at the
other end of that feeling great.
So important to take a variety of
different things that are good for your
health.
In my opinion,
you should really eat a lot of healthy
vegetables.
That's like one of the most important
things.
One of the strongest things I've ever
done is increase the amount of like
green leafy vegetables in my diet and
drink kale shakes and shit like that.
Take multivitamins please.
It's not hard.
It's fucking easy and it'll make you
healthier.
It just,
it will make you feel better.
Eat good food,
you know,
and and look into nootropics if you're
not into any of the shit that we have at
[inaudible] dot com.
There's plenty of other people that have
cool shit available,
so we try to make it as easy and as
clean as possible.
I'm way more concerned than I say this
every fucking time,
but it's because it's true.
I'm way more concerned with not ripping
people off than I am with making money.
So that's the end of that fucking
horseshit button.
Let's start the show.
Duncan trussell.
I cut way back on my coffee consumption.
I have found that coffee and the show go
well together.
Oh yeah.
I think they're important in order to
just keep spitting information out.
This is this.
What are you doing with that Echo,
man?
You're killing me.
Won't go waiting for it.
It won't go away.
Period.
To be crazy,
man.
That's how it feels like when you're
tripping,
like you smoke too much weed and you
start having a panic attack that started
going on.
It's almost there.
It's almost kind of his own.
Such a delay.
It's,
it's just a weird,
stupid,
special effect that I do.
Do you always do the same one?
No,
it doesn't.
Usually.
I usually mix it up.
Does this make you feel better when you
do these things?
Yeah,
it's just a cool intro.
You know?
Might as well start off with a weird,
creepy noise.
Doug and trust is here.
How we can.
We don't have to get any weird or creepy
or not creepy in a bad way,
brother.
Creeping the best possible way.
You know,
I love you.
We all love you.
I love you guys were doing the Chicago
Theater,
uh,
this Friday night.
Fucking super fired up in me and Joey
Coco motherfucking Diaz in the flesh if
you,
if you have never had a chance to see
Joey Diaz live going to shit yourself.
That guy,
dude,
he had his moments.
He had some moments on stage where it's
just ridiculous shit that he says.
It just makes you repeat what he said
over and over and over again.
He's one of those dudes when he,
when Joey like really rocks it on stage,
he'll say one of the something so
fucking completely preposterous and so
out of control that you'll just be
repeating it.
You'd be like,
he's fucking.
You'll just repeat what he said.
Like over and over.
He had the reregistration your head
almost like did I really just had his
fucking that transvestite joke.
One of the greatest jokes anybody's ever
told onstage.
He goes,
I like transvestites.
They Cook,
they clean.
They couldn't beat on him.
Every once in awhile the cops come who
they're gonna,
believe me or some dude with a wig and a
black guy.
There's no support groups for these
people.
The cops come,
who is it going to believe me?
Dude,
a wig and a black.
That's just,
that's just poetry,
man.
To me,
that's poetry.
You know,
like the,
the amount of words used,
the structure of it,
the great jazz.
A fucking animal.
Chili ideas is an animal.
It's so
funny,
man.
We had them on the podcast the other
day.
Dude,
just talk.
He can talk about anything.
Toothpicks.
I know a fucking.
Due to my two picks on a fucking crazy
story about a big factor in this chick
was sucking everybody's Dick.
You know what I'm saying?
So Papa had to get his exist.
Toothpick factory story will become some
fucking epic.
He's fucking.
That's ever lived.
He's the greatest team of.
Bring this up.
I fucking love that guy.
That's one of the most awesome things
about living here.
Is that all you guys are here.
That's one of the things that kind of
keeps me in this area right now because
all you guys are here,
it's like we have a lot of cool friends.
We have a very unusual situation.
We need to all move at the same exact
thing.
We need to get together like an occupy
Wall Street thing and be like,
all right,
we're all moving.
At the same time.
We got to be prepared for civil unrest
because the government is okay.
So we've got to start thinking if the
shit went down,
we need a goddamn ranch somewhere.
Yep.
You know,
a ranch somewhere with like a bunch of
houses,
a castle,
and Joe all live in this nice little
farming ranch community until the dust
settles.
Yeah,
you can do that,
man.
It's good to have a place like that to
go to.
Man.
I've got to a place like that to go to,
but yeah,
I do.
But I did it in North Carolina.
It's in Jacksonville,
North Carolina.
It's in Georgia.
I will not reveal the precise location
near the Georgia guidestones.
Oh,
I wish it was.
Now it's not,
it's not near the Georgia guidestones.
I don't know where those are actually,
but I'm sure those are either.
Let's find out how you going to do that,
but go ahead.
Brought Dr.
but you got it.
I think it's a smart thing to have.
I mean,
in any fucking house you want to have,
you want to way if you're in a hotel or
wherever,
it's good to know where to go if there's
going to be a fire.
It's the same thing with civilization.
It's not.
I mean,
it doesn't make you crazy.
It just makes you a normal thinking
person.
Elbert County,
uh,
Elbert county's where in Galveston
County,
the Georgia guidestones,
it'll large granite monument in Elbert
County,
Georgia.
Yeah.
A message that contains 10 guides is
inscribed on the structure in eight
modern languages.
And a shorter message is inscribed at
the top of the structure in,
for ancient language scripts.
Babylonian,
classical Greek sand script in Egypt,
in hieroglyphs.
You should have some pretty intense
shit,
man.
Yeah,
I mean this is someone saying,
you know,
look,
if humanity completely falls apart,
here's a message,
get to this stuff.
This is crucial information.
Somebody should have told them that
there's not a lot of people in southern
Georgia that speak classical
Greek.
This is what it says on.
It's really very interesting because
it's very wise words.
Listen to this.
Maintain humanity under $500,
million in perpetual balance with
nature,
500 million on the whole planet.
Good idea.
Guide reproduction wisely.
Improving fitness and diversity.
Eugenics.
That sounds a little eugenics,
but rational as well,
right?
I mean,
you know,
utopian,
of course Utopian but rash,
right?
Okay.
Unite humanity with a living new
language.
We all had one language that would make
everything a lot fucking easier.
Right?
Rule,
passion,
faith,
tradition,
and all things with tempered reason.
Sound words,
write some words.
Protect people and nations with fair
laws and just courts.
Okay.
Let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court.
I don't hear any new world order shit
yet.
Right?
Avoid petty laws and useless officials a
bit.
Subjective.
Well,
I mean a lot of this stuff is subject.
This is pretty subjective though,
right?
Hey laws and useless officials saying,
resolve your problems in a world court.
What?
How do you do that?
That seems like a weird one.
The petty laws and useless officials.
It seems silly.
That seems like it should be.
You know,
maybe.
Well,
price is a good one.
Bounce personal rights with social
duties.
Agreed.
That's smart,
right?
Strong communities.
Shit.
Yeah.
Prize truth.
Beauty.
Love seeking harmony with the infinite.
Okay.
Now you're getting a little crystally.
It sounds almost like Dr.
Bronner's soap.
It's like that shit on Dr.
Okay,
here we hear here.
Now I don't like it at all.
Listen,
be not a cancer on the earth,
leave room for nature,
leave room for nature.
Now I don't like it because that's a
stupid thing to say.
First of all,
be not a cancer on the earth.
What do you Shakespeare Bitch,
you,
they don't have cancer.
Don't be cancer.
Cancer,
silly.
I guess if you're not going to use
contractions,
maybe you think contractions with real
people.
I think.
Here's the thing that I think is really
funny about these stones and about like,
I just watched cave of forgotten dreams,
which is pretty awesome.
Um,
which is like they went,
didn't get into it,
man.
I,
I shut it off halfway and I got bored.
I thought I got into it because I was
just thinking about how crazy it was.
The rhinos were in France at one point
and kind of like who the fuck are these
people?
It was a little dry,
but if you carve something in stone and
you put it deep enough in this stone and
are big enough stone,
it's guaranteed that if people are still
around in like hundreds of thousands of
years,
they're going to think that that really
meant something,
you know,
they're going to think it was very
important just because you carved it in
stone,
so it could be anything.
You could put anything on a cave wall
and people will come in and look at and
be like,
wow,
look at this.
They're either they worshiped a penis
with a with a happy face on it and it's
just a guy like painted something on
Georgia guidestones.
It's just some guy went and carved some
shit and stone makes
sense.
I mean I just be not a cancer on
the earth.
Leave Room for nature.
That means that is.
I mean I'm,
we're goofing on it,
but that is like a good thought.
I think they're great for all of it.
Seems like.
Okay.
It's just.
I don't think that there's anything.
Well,
it's like twitter messages.
You can't get too profound when you're
carving in stone.
Yeah.
You're carving on a fucking,
a limited amount of space.
Uh,
yeah.
What,
what would you tell people if you,
if you had Georgia guidestones of your
own,
if you could leave behind some monument
to future monkey people that figure this
out again?
Yeah.
You know what?
So many,
so many quoted.
It was a fascinating quote.
That civilization,
if you,
if you look at it as made by the
brightest minds,
is disappointing.
It's disappointing where we are,
but if you look at it as something
that's been thrown together by monkeys,
it's amazing.
Amazing.
We're doing so good right now.
If you think about how good we're doing,
we're doing great,
but isn't that an interesting thing that
you know,
that people know that human beings are
capable of so much better,
so much better behavior,
so much more of a,
of a safe,
sane,
rational,
loving world.
We're capable that we're all capable of
that as an,
as individuals will cave.
We're all capable of being loving and
nice and friendly,
and if we're all capable of it.
Then in groups we spread out and then
somehow or another it gets lost along
the way.
So where does it get lost on the way
when they're fighting over resources,
when they're fighting over,
you know,
crazy ideas.
Yeah.
The ideas.
Mostly it's the problem is the ideas.
It's the resources thing.
If you have resources you can work out.
If you don't have crazy ideas,
research resources,
you can work out.
It's the fucking crazy ideas.
I just saw that guy,
the physicist.
Well,
I can never pronounce his name.
Moceanu.
What's this?
He's a genius in Chicago.
Yes.
He,
uh,
he was talking about the different types
of civilization type zero civilization
type one civilization type two
civilization.
I think someone just put it on my
facebook wall,
but basically the concept behind it is
that right now we're moving from a type
zero civilization to a type one
civilization,
which is we're going into a place where
we're going to recognize that we're all,
you know,
uh,
or planetary.
You know what I mean?
We're a planetary civilization instead
of broken up and all these weird
divergent pieces where they all speak
different languages and we have these
different beliefs.
We're moving into something where we're
all connected via the internet,
but he said this is the most dangerous
time possible because we're moving from
type zero type one and the type zero
people,
the ones with the crazy ideas,
they have nuclear weapons and so we're
in a place where if we don't work this
shit out there can be,
we can destroy ourselves,
but if we can get past these crazy ideas
that differentiate us,
that split us up the shit where people
say like,
you know,
those marines just pissed on,
on,
uh,
on the Taliban that they shot.
And everybody got upset about that.
Everybody got upset about.
They got upset that they were pissing on
him.
They didn't get upset that they killed.
They were like,
how could you urinate on bodies?
It's like,
you just blew fucking holes in the
chest.
These men,
that's horrifying.
That's awful.
That's the worst still at a place right
now where it's worse to piss on a dead
body.
Then to make a dead body,
now when we get to a place where making
a dead body has the same cultural
resonance is pissing on one where it
makes national news because one person
had the fucking insane idea of like
shooting someone instead of working it
out through language or talking it out.
That's when we're going to be in or
entering a new age and new if we can
make it there.
A new evolutionary period where we
recognize that a solution to a problem
is never is never blasting people to
smithereens.
And if it is,
it's so fucking rare that like it's the
most rare thing.
It's only in the most rare situations,
you know?
So I think that I think we're on the
verge of getting to this place and I
think the Internet is helping.
I think every time you look at what
happened with Sopa and Pipa and you see
the power of this organizing force and
logic seems to rule in the Internet.
It's just logical people.
The logical majority seems to be making
things happen.
So if that happened on a planetary scale
where instead of these fucking insane
guys like the president of Syria,
good at freak.
If you seen that fucking guy,
he's insane.
He's insane.
Dictator,
you know,
it's like these people that wasn't a
move.
Mubarak and what's his name in Egypt?
What was his name?
Mubarak was like,
guys,
you think it's okay to be president for
40 years straight?
You know what I mean?
These fucking assholes.
Once we start getting them out of the
picture,
you know,
and then move on to the fucking the
clerics and the Prius two or like
teaching people that are the only way to
communicate with the university.
Connect with God.
Once we get rid of those motherfuckers.
This is pretty awesome planet man.
The resources thing.
We can work it out.
We can work out the resources.
I think we could.
Smart.
I couldn't maybe,
but someone
love it.
Awesome.
Optimistic view of the world.
If we could just all communicate in the
same native language so we could tell
each other this.
Yeah.
That's a big part of the problem.
Be Part of the problem is if you were,
if there was some sort of a civil unrest
or some sort of a problem with another
part of the country that was European,
we would get all the information back
immediately.
What's going on?
Exactly what's going on.
Can you imagine like the United States
was in Ireland for some reason.
Oh my God.
Wow.
It would be ridiculous.
You know,
and also this,
this level,
this language,
this new language that I,
that it wouldn't just be us talking the
same language.
It's a neurologically,
it's an,
it's a technological neurological
interface that allows us to directly
communicate emotion to each other
because it's like imagine how many
stupid arguments you've gotten in like
with your girlfriend or with your
friends that you.
It's,
it just is about language.
We're underneath it.
You're just feeling the exact.
You're just like,
I really want things to be okay and
you're right.
You know what I mean?
So if you could just feel how that felt
were,
because I mean,
think about it.
We're forced to articulate our universe
through the same fucking Oregon that we
use to chew hamburgers.
That's our way of describing the entire,
it's the tip of our feeding tubes is how
we're forced to describe the infinite.
We're fucking limited.
It's like in my left foot when the guy
could only paint with his foot.
Remember that we have infinity out here
and all we have to access to,
to describe this infinity and our
perception of it in the way it feels to
be a part of it is a language that we
didn't come up with ourselves.
The language has been passed down in
his,
uh,
you know,
it was a trade language.
So a lot of the words that we have,
there might not be words that exist
right now to describe certain facets of
reality and sometimes that'll make them
invisible.
But if you could undercut language and
just have a emotional fucking connection
where you could feel another person's
emotions.
I mean,
imagine being the president of Syria and
you come in,
you the guide is like killing
protesters,
you know,
jailing people and torturing them.
You take that guy and just for one
second,
he gets a feeling of what it's like to
be out in the street or to be in a
country where you've had a president
forever and you're being completely
repressed.
If he could feel that feeling,
you know what I mean?
It would be hard for him to continue on.
It will be hard for them to live and
delusion and to think that,
oh,
I see.
It's easy to be a tyrant.
I deserve this,
or these people are less than me.
Slavery never would've been able to
happen.
Slavery was based on this ridiculous
idea that somehow black people deserve
to be enslaved.
You know?
It's the same thing with eating meat.
We believe that in general people one
one way,
not everyone.
Some mediators are like,
yeah,
I,
I'll,
I'll eat.
I eat meat and I know that these animals
have feelings and generally die of
brutal life,
but I think I deserve to eat meat and I
think that's natural.
That's the best rationale for eating
meat.
That's it.
You acknowledge the suffering and pain
you're causing and you do it and you do
it because you think you deserve it,
but some people they think fucking
animals are like clockwork things.
You know what I mean?
Like little mechanistic,
like a wristwatch,
and they don't feel the same things that
we feel and we'll never know that until
we create a neurological interface with
animals in the moment you realized,
oh fuck man,
these cows,
they feel love.
They feel love for each other and fear
and they fucking more than their kids.
Then when you sit down and eat a
hamburger,
it's going to be a much more intense
experience.
It's maybe it'll make it taste better.
I don't know,
but it's going to be this cow new love.
Do A.
is that all true what you said about
the.
Well,
no,
I don't think we.
I don't think we can know that,
but I think that there are like the,
my,
like when I was in India,
they like the cows kind of wander the
streets and they don't.
They're not like,
you know,
they're not abused in the same way that
they are here.
I'm sure there are some,
but the ones they're like,
they're like really sweet dogs.
They'll come up to you and rub their
muzzle against you and you can scratch
behind their ears and they're just very
sweet.
I mean,
I'm not saying cows are fucking dolphin
of cows.
Eventually evolve it.
Just get
a little bit smarter and learn how to
speak English and then like start coming
into people's houses and see all the
leather shit.
What the fuck you,
you abandon you imagine?
I mean we just assumed the cows are
never going to evolve because of where
they are right now is where they are.
You know,
we assume they're just gonna fucking eat
the grass and just be all stupid and not
get anything done.
Just run around and make milk.
They started allowing them on buses.
Yeah.
What if,
what if,
what if something happens would have.
Maybe it's radiation.
Maybe it's like some fucking third world
country where we would make in Nike's
and they did something to the water
supply and it makes cow super smart.
Funny Dude.
Can you imagine that?
The Lord Jesus Christ,
you have leather.
Everything you fuckheads you think you
think it's cool to have leather?
Everything we have,
like the skin of a murdered animal is
like standard on cars.
That's our favorite shit.
We want to sit down and flesh peeled
flesh from an murdered animal is the
preferred seating choice.
Yeah.
That's how I like my seat covered.
I'd like affirm nice back of have
murdered animal hide with minimal
padding.
Yeah.
Isn't it odd though that like even if
like I,
you know,
for if I died,
I mean maybe I'm wrong about this,
but if I put my will,
I want my,
I want my flesh cured and made into
wallets for my friends.
I don't think I could legally do that.
I don't think you can do that.
You know?
I don't think you could do that either.
People that so superstitious and odd.
Well it is,
but you don't want to really open up
that market.
You don't want to give any flashmarket
wallet market,
man.
You don't even want to open that door.
Well,
I do.
You don't want have any of those out
there.
You know why?
Because there's some one dude and he
just,
he's going to get through this miserable
life in one piece,
one way or another until one day he's at
the flea market and he finds a human
flesh wallet and that's it.
He's got to make human flesh everything.
Boom.
Murder spree making human flesh
underwear.
Yeah.
Not Good.
You don't want to encourage that kind of
shit.
You can't have that out there.
You can't have human flesh wallets out
there.
People just to unpredictably fucked up.
I won't do it.
I will.
I'll cancel my kickstarter account.
That's going to be a real problem and
it's not just communicating.
It's figuring out how to develop people
or redevelop them after they'd been
fucked up as children,
that there's going to be something they
figured some sort of a reset.
Well,
again,
if you can get an emotional read on a
person like how they're experiencing
reality,
then you can communicate with them much
better.
I mean some,
some,
some people are fucked.
Communicate
smart as a species.
That's one of the big things that we
would do.
We would set up places where people who
had fucked her lives up can go and not
be a criminal and get some food and have
so many help them figure things out
like,
listen,
what do we know we can keep you from
going to jail for the rest of your life?
Let's let's work this out.
Let's fucking figure you out a fucking
career path here.
Help this dude.
Somebody helped.
These people are obviously everybody's
pulling yourself up by your own
bootstraps,
which I believe in for for most things.
For most things.
That would be the advice,
but occasionally there's some people
that are a part of society.
They're just,
they're handed the shittiest fucking
hand of cards ever in life and you know,
and then they find themselves in and out
of the judicial system as a young kid
and they find themselves in jail.
I mean,
it's like,
man,
you don't think that that dude somehow
or another,
she didn't get a fair shake ever in his
whole life.
You know,
and everybody just wants to just lock
them up and put them in.
That's not the solution either.
The solution is how you fix them.
It's so weird,
man.
It's like the vagina is an elevator door
that opens up into this dimension.
And like sometimes that elevator puts
you out on a bad fucking place.
That is one of the most brilliant things
you've ever said.
That elevator smells.
You gotta.
Remember that?
Somebody tweet that to doug.
I remember that.
That's a bit,
dude.
I've been saying
some version of that but I'm not like
that.
But.
So the idea is you get smashed out into
the,
in some of these people get fucked up.
They get blasted out into a bad
apartment surrounded by crackheads.
Deal.
It's terrifying.
Yeah man.
And,
and,
and this fucking.
What does this lead to?
This leads to what you're talking about.
These people who,
who have,
I mean,
imagine spending the first 12 years of
your life before you went into a foster
home with the most neurons when you're,
uh,
when you're a baby,
as more neurons in their brain than at
any other time in their life.
So you're like,
as a wax seal,
a baby's brain is like a wax seal and
the fucking family is like the ring that
you know,
they pushed into like,
and like in the fucking like medieval
times.
It's like we get imprinted and we can't
resist it by the vibrational frequencies
that were around when we're,
when we're blasted into this dimension
and,
and you need help to get those things
transformed.
Like you can't just do it on your own.
The record's been pressed,
man.
You need help to fucking overcome the
weird patterns that come from living
next to the lunatics that were your
parents.
Not everyone had crazy parents,
but many people had fucked up parents.
They were giving like think about how
young.
I mean,
I think our younger parents were when
they had you think about that,
where they are in their twenties.
Joe,
my,
when my mother was 21 when she had me.
When was the last time you talked to a
21 year old last night for am.
That's all I needed to know.
Brian lives in that world.
He lives in the world of.
He's the only 37 year old man I know
that uses the word like
I've,
I'm guilty.
I'm like,
this guy's like,
and I'm like,
get out here.
And I do that.
I liked it.
I do the likes,
man.
I,
I listened to these youtube videos
sometimes people make in a year,
might lag,
lag lag.
It makes me want to.
So my lip.
Well that's a cool thing about podcasts
is you get to find out how annoying your
personality really is.
The annoying aspects of it gets
highlighted.
Yeah.
I just get back in your face.
It's good to see.
It really is.
There's A.
I've read this,
there's an interesting essay that this
guy got the weirdest name.
His name's Suzanne and he's,
uh,
he's like,
I don't know the exact word for what he
is,
but he's like an anarchist primitive as
he thinks.
Everything started going bad when we
started using symbols to represent
reality instead of just being in reality
when the moment you start using symbols
to represent reality,
you're kind of boxing reality in and
you're separating yourself.
You're creating the separation from you
and the universe.
And so he was talking about the growing
use of the term,
like how people use the word,
like instead of just saying what it is,
so you know,
it's like you're walking outside and
you're like,
come up to this thing and you're like.
And he says,
what that is is this subconscious
problem where people are not directly
experiencing reality.
So everything's like something else.
Things aren't being,
things are being like something else.
It's very curious that it's pretty good
if you look up Suzanne,
that's,
it's,
it's a little fucking dense,
but it's a pretty good essay.
Have you ever hung out with guys a hate
symbols that hate symbols and drums?
No.
To either one of those instruments?
Well,
you know,
it's weird.
You know,
I'm,
one of the things that I always thought
it was fascinating about ancient
Egyptian hieroglyphs is that they,
they had a completely different way of
writing things.
So they must've had a completely
different way of talking dip,
completely different way of phrasing
things.
And uh,
and you,
you,
when you look at like how you could be a
human being,
obviously an intelligent human being,
advanced sophisticated culture,
capable of producing amazing works of
art,
but that language is like totally alien
to us.
Like we look at it and like what is this
crazy chicken scratch and pictures of
birds and shit and these fucking people,
this is what they use to describe the
world.
But somehow or another to them it
worked.
Like they,
they,
they thought of things like in a
different way.
Their,
their language,
their written language consisted of like
symbols.
Yeah.
You know,
not,
not like ours but like,
you know,
but like images,
really fascinating shit.
Yeah,
it is.
Languages is one of the most fascinating
things to think about when you're
tripping.
Like it's fun to contemplate where each
word is coming from,
like the transformation
of the thought into the word and how
instantaneous that happened.
So when you start contemplating where at
where's this,
where's this language coming from?
I don't even think about this.
It just,
it just happened.
And for the longest time,
for the longest time,
people have always been aware that one
of the big things that keeps people from
really directly communicating with
everybody is the language barrier.
Yes.
I mean that's why the myth of the Tower
of Babel existed,
that,
that was like a plan to give us all
different languages so we can never
fucking figure out how to communicate
with each other.
Which is really fascinating because it
really would make sense.
Like if someone had that kind of power,
if we lose like a warlock who could just
go and we'll give everyone a different
language.
God,
that would be a good move.
If you really could do that.
I mean if it was that easy to be the
architect of reality,
that would be a good move.
You don't want them to rally up.
We'll have them all live in these little
spots and give him the fucking languages
and shit.
No one understands what you're
say.
If I went over to God's house,
like if there's a lot of God's living in
the same neighborhood and they all have
these little aquarium earth they're
fucking with,
none of them were shy.
Went over to a fucking.
Got The God's House that did that.
Feel like you're a dick man.
Let them speak the same language and
have fun.
Why are you?
Why do you consistently fuck with these
people?
You got to give them a break.
I,
you know what I call animal control on
God.
Like look at it.
Look like if you believe the concept of
God and really think about like the
fundamentalist Christian concept of God,
if this,
if any,
if someone was doing that to animals,
what God is apparently doing to us
according to the fundamentalist
Christians,
he would go to jail for a long time.
Anonymous would fucking attacking God's
a sadist.
He's like taking gay people,
burning them in hell forever.
He's like giving cancer to people
because they deserve it.
He makes people go blind.
He turned a whole city in the Bible.
That salt or something.
Yeah,
he did a lot of creepy shit.
He's a creep.
There's no other way around it.
There's better ways to deal with it.
People you don't understand.
Dunkin,
the Lord has a plan in all the Ode to
you in your mind.
You believe you have it all figured out
and then you're smarter than the Lower
Nicei.
That's not possible.
You're a talker,
you're a mocker.
I can remember this.
You're thinking too much.
They get mad at you.
Well,
can I have questions?
That's not what.
That's not what you shouldn't use your
mind for that.
You got to let God be scripture sales,
right?
Scripture say he who walk with me walk
with the Lord will say shit like that.
And he goes,
what does that even mean?
What the fuck does that mean?
Well,
I mean,
what it means.
That means that's the dude with the
mushrooms.
Well,
yeah,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's.
So that's the sad thing is these,
there's a great book called,
it's by Abraham maslow and it's called
religious values and peak and it talks
about a theoretical,
the theory,
the theory of how a religion happens and
the progression of information as it
goes from being someone who's really
happy to it being a priest class that's
controlling people.
And so his idea is certain people
throughout time have had peak
experiences where they break through
that particular ego barrier created by
the Zeitgeists of their time.
They have a direct communication with
some kind of like super ideas,
superintelligence,
whatever you want to call it.
They get really happy,
happy in a way.
Not just like someone who's having a
good day,
but in a way where if you ran into them,
you would recognize it.
They'd figured something out.
So that person gets a group of people
around him who are kind of magnetized by
the energy and by what they're saying
and they're talking about are a real way
that you can live and actually be happy
in the world.
And those people from being around
someone who's like,
you know,
like in sports they used to say you can
own a five minute mile,
you could only run a mile and this
amount of time.
And everyone thought that everyone was
doing that.
And then right when someone broke it,
all of a sudden everyone started
breaking.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I could do that.
So in the same way these certain people
will overcome a specific,
you know,
a phantom of their time,
which is causing them to be miserable.
Those people get people around them will
also get this certain level of
happiness.
The person who came up with the original
idea dies.
Now he's just got the disciples and the
disciples that people around them and
they transmit this idea to the people
are on him.
But now it's a little diluted in some of
the people we were doing and aren't
quite,
aren't really quite happy.
They're not doing it right.
So you pass that down,
keeps getting water,
getting watered and watered and watered.
And then the next thing you know,
you just,
you,
you have like some fucking,
like old horny man with his pants down,
just nailing a toddler and a confession
booth and,
and,
and that,
that's the end result.
Starts off with this super happy guy,
ends up with a fucking pedophile dress
like a god clown with his cock and a
kid's ass.
That's how,
that's how mutated things get.
Which is why it's very funny that people
feel so desperate to cling onto this old
thing instead of thinking,
wait,
there might be a new thing that we can
come up with based on all the
information we have right now.
The end
of the day,
it's all shit that was written down by
people at the end of the day.
Yeah.
And why would we ever think that the
people who lived thousands of years ago
had it?
Right.
Okay.
Why?
Why would you want to believe that?
There might be information there that we
could use and could help us.
But the most important thing is to know
what we know now.
Yes.
No.
What do we know now?
And let's figure this fucking thing out
together.
That's right.
Following some.
Any crazy shit.
Anything.
I don't care what it is.
Judaism,
Christianity,
Muslim.
What do you want to be?
I want to be a car.
Krishna.
It's awesome.
It's all the same.
It's all something that someone put put
together.
What?
The message behind it.
Who?
Who knows if it's right.
Who knows if it's wrong.
Who knows if there really is a,
an actual man,
the fucking clouds.
And in the biblical sense,
who the fuck knows?
I mean,
I,
I.
It doesn't seem likely to me based on
what I've experienced in my life,
but if it is going to be pissed,
but even if it is,
I mean the university is fucking so
bizarre.
The.
Yeah.
Just the idea of the infinite space is
so bizarre that a guy in the clouds with
a horrible.
Why is that so weird?
I mean,
yeah,
why not?
Fucking why not?
Why not?
There'd be one guy that's running the
whole fucking.
What the fuck you,
you know,
it sounds crazy that there could be a
heaven,
a pearly gates and shit,
and you get up there and there's dudes
wearing white and everybody's floating.
But imagine if it was true.
Imagine if you got up,
you,
I wouldn't.
That is not to me nearly as shocking.
Heaven is not nearly as shocking as the
universe itself.
Well,
I,
I think that it's what we're talking
about here is that the ability to
describe reality and to,
and to uh,
understand reality.
It keeps increasing as we evolve as a
species.
So a really smart people and you know,
in every single time there's been very
smart people at every single time,
really smart people in different ways,
but their ability to describe reality
was limited to the language available to
them and the technology that was around
them at the time.
I mean,
if you look at like,
Shit,
man,
I hope you remember this because there's
a book in the Old Testament that is in
my mind is clearly a Ufo encounter.
I think it's not leviticus,
it's as equal.
Now you look at that and what is the guy
who used to describe this thing?
We'll within the Marriott's.
Yeah,
wheels and chariots and just the shit
that's available to him to describe this
experience that he had now.
Now if someone saw that same thing,
they'd be like,
yeah,
I got sucked up by a Ufo.
They gave me a psychedelic.
I saw something that's coming which is
relevant
or period coconut felon that
motherfucker's head and sparks were
flying and he didn't know what happened.
He woke up in a ditch with a bloody head
with a have been loosening far.
It could have been allison nation and
and people just believed it,
but I think that,
I mean outside of religious
hallucinations or visions and people
trying to describe it,
everyone's limited to the tools that
they have around them to observe reality
and they can only report on reality
based on the tools that they had
and the experiences that they have to
draw upon.
Which is one of the reasons why the
whole Ufo thing seemed so preposterous
to people.
It's so we don't have that experience to
draw upon the experience of an alien
intelligent life form.
It's like looking back at us while we're
looking at it,
I don't think.
I think 90 percent of the people on the
planet which is die of a heart attack,
like immediately,
boom,
to fucking explode.
Yeah.
If aliens came and they were super
intelligent with big fucking gray heads
and those giant black guys,
they can totally read your mind and they
were all just like floating and freezing
people and erasing memories and shit.
Like all these Travis Walton stories.
You know that guy that if that's all,
if that were to actually happen,
I don't think the human race would
survive.
I think we,
we can't serve.
We're the alpha.
We can't exist in a world where we're
under the thumb of some incredibly
intelligent,
super sophisticated alien life form that
thinks in a completely different way
than us and can control matter.
Well,
you know man,
I,
I always,
I have this optimistic idea of actual
matter like I'm working writing for the
x amount.
It's not going to.
I don't think it's going to come from
the sky and the silver ships.
I think the way it goes down is it maybe
all of a sudden you kind of.
We as a species get to a point where we
kind of realized we remember actually
what's going on.
I think right now we have a little bit
of Amnesia.
We have lost a,
a,
a sense of like what truly is happening.
I think when you take a really potent
psychedelic,
sometimes you'll see this universe that
already is around you that's already
happening around you at all times.
You get a sense all of a sudden that
you've been there before and then it
goes away.
But it seems like we're more like
getting projected into this reality with
awful amnesia.
For some,
I don't know what it's for.
It could be,
it could be just a video game.
Could be a,
uh,
a sadistic joke could be a prank.
This could be a prank that one super
intelligent entities playing on another
superintelligent enemy entity.
It could be anything.
Or it can be a novelty creating machine.
Like on Mckenna thought that the
universe is a novelty creating and
harvesting machine and that we as the
most complex organisms possibly in the
universe where we're at at the pinnacle
of this novelty creation.
Yeah,
man.
That's like,
that's.
That's the whole reason for it all.
It seems chaotic to us and say,
look,
this is preposterous.
We should know better,
but it's almost like in our instincts as
an organism,
we have a direction to go and the
direction is not spiritual.
It's technological.
That's it.
People are not looking for some sort of
a spiritual release and some sort of a,
a,
a broader perspective on the universe in
an objective view of life.
No.
They're looking to see if they can punch
a hole through the center of space.
You know what I mean?
It's those real height of progress is
not a complete overhauling and
understanding of the educational system
of the way to develop human minds,
the way to stop people from harming each
other instead of devoting all of our
resources to evolving socially.
If it even is possible ever.
Instead of doing that
well,
one,
one thing you can do is instead of when
you think about the passage of time as
we move into the future,
if you like,
get out of your head,
this idea,
it's like running down a race track or
something like you're running down a
track and think of it more in the sense
of a revealing is happening.
So as we progress into the future,
more things begin to emerge into this
reality that weren't there before.
Like we go from having stone tools to
all of a sudden having a,
you know,
iron tools and then we go from that to
all of a sudden you know,
where we are now,
where we're surrounded by fucking
silver,
glowing macintosh computers and like
microphones that are somehow recording
our voice and these things keep getting
revealed more and more and more.
And any of these items should you take
them back 100 years,
people would think it was a Ufo.
They'd see it and think that fell out of
a space ship.
So all of a sudden you realize,
and maybe Mckenna said this,
I think he may have said something like
this,
but the idea is the spaceship,
the alien,
the extra terrestrial intelligence.
It's growing around us like crystals
when you were a kid and you're growing
crystals,
but it's growing in the form of
technology that eventually is going on
to become self aware,
which is why I heard this awesome thing,
which is the first alien contact that we
have is going to be a computer that
wakes up,
that's going to be our first
communication with another
consciousness.
Not something from the great void of
space,
but something that grew through time.
I
say,
I said that's totally possible,
but I don't say not something from
space.
So as it could be something from space.
Yeah,
that's possible too.
I hope it is.
It could be that the first Ufo or the
first,
you know,
uh,
the first real intelligence that we
encountered this greater than our own is
something that we create ourselves at
replicates itself through us.
Like very quickly.
Like that was the idea that once a
computer becomes the real issue is going
to be that they're going to be able to
live.
This is a stupid fucking design who
built me and then they build something
like way better.
That's it.
Instantly they know exactly how to put
it together once they and you know the
idea of programming emotions and
programming are a million system of,
of dealing with babies and puppies and
little baby chickie's and shit.
They won't have any of that guilt or
weird feeling about biological life and
they might just say,
look at these fucking assholes shitting
all over this planet.
We can't even use half of the resources
on the planet because it's fuck heads
have blown up nuclear bombs.
Nuclear waste and holes were like cats
will like take our nuclear ships and we
just throw them in a hole and then we
cover over.
It was like stupid cats at the top of
the heap of technological innovation and
science.
The best way to get rid of nuclear
waste.
Besides shooting it at other planets,
could you imagine what assholes we would
be considered in the universe?
If we just shot our nuclear waste up
into space like a rocket,
you know,
we send it out with the voyager to crash
lands on someone's fucking moon someday,
or what if it starts some future war?
They think it's a bomb we send,
we shoot nuclear waste.
There were just.
Apparently it's very devastating to
their particular kills,
like 80 percent of the people on the
planet,
the rest they get together on giant bow
ships and had to earth so fucking good
movies.
Somebody make that,
make that movie.
Would they,
could they show shoot nuclear waste in
this space?
Can they do that?
Well,
it gets stuck in the problem with that.
Is it my.
Yeah,
I'm sure you could,
but it would take.
It takes so much energy to get it out of
the orbit of the planet that it ends up
becoming less efficient to use nuclear
energy.
You know,
they blew up a bomb in the,
uh,
the atmospheric operation,
I believe.
I think it was called operation
starfish.
Prime Corner knows the name of it.
Yeah.
Let me Google that.
So don't starfish prime day involved?
No,
no,
no.
For real man,
they they decided to shoot a fucking
nuclear warhead.
The ionosphere wouldn't like fuck up
some kind of rotation or something or
possibly.
Well,
you don't want it to fall back.
Yeah.
Oh,
you mean blowing up a fucking in the
atmosphere?
I think at that time they didn't really
know what it was.
What did I say?
What's prime?
What?
Oh,
fuck.
Something primed.
I starfish starfish.
That sounds like initiate starfish.
Primary daughters get album,
doesn't it?
It's a good nickname for somebody
starfish.
Pretty good.
Lipiscan.
It's like a nickname for a stripper and
as karate and I was like a weed street.
Wow.
One of five high altitude tests.
She's Christ.
They shot a bunch of fucking nuclear
bombs up in the space just to see what
would happen.
Oh,
these people are so crazy.
Crazy people.
People that we got running our world are
so fucking hilarious.
When the people that created weapons.
Sure.
The people that decided to like test
tube and blow shit up and see what you
ever.
You've seen the video of the one nuclear
bomb that they blew up in the ocean
where there's all these battleships
around it and the water,
I'm like,
I dunno,
like half a mile into the sky and it's
just,
it's so ridiculous.
The people exaggerating.
Am I even exaggerating?
I might not be mad.
I'm like,
I wish I was more than 100 feet.
It was ridiculously high in the sky and
these are battleships,
dude,
like big ass battleships and this water
just flying through the air like
somebody made that,
that will have a group of people.
They made that and then they just
fucking did it.
They just did it.
Let's see what it looks like.
That's fucking fascinating that it
must've been when it was only
theoretical when there was all these anc
had sitting around just ending the these
ideas,
oppenheimer and Einstein and all these
motherfuckers with their ideas come
together and they think it could be done
and they know it could be.
It's almost like science compels them to
create it.
Well,
science knowing that's the PR.
That's that.
That right there errors.
The danger,
because things get weird at that point,
like those fucking signed someone is in
control,
but other than the scientists themselves
and someone always will be and the
people that will be would never be able
to create that in the first place.
They would never be able to come up with
this intellectually.
That's why scientists are.
It's a very interesting thing because
they have this idea.
They're just seeking knowledge.
They're Catholics.
No more out.
That's what they do and then you know,
but the people paying them to do this or
gender.
It's quite often the military,
but look at these fucking guys who just
invented that new bird flu.
Did you hear about this?
Running it through ferret kidneys or
something they created.
I don't remember how they did.
It was like running it through ferrets.
So they created apparently something
that.
What was the,
what is it?
Thirty percent of the people who got to
die or kill something insane.
They said it.
It would make smallpox look like the
common called smallpox is already
something that if,
if if there was a smallpox outbreak,
we'd be fucked.
We beat smallpox.
Now.
Why are they making fucking super dizzy?
Because they're just trying to find
information.
They're exploring the universe and so
that's their motivation.
Yet what they did is they created a
biological nuclear weapon.
Now she's all over the fucking planet.
There's people in the military mean when
someone.
I'm sure that some military commander
which is looking through there.
I was like,
Oh Martha,
can you get data scientists on the line?
I'd like to talk to them and they're
like,
Hey,
do you guys want to make $17,000,000
this week?
Send over your research.
We'd like to know how to make this
biological agent,
and then the next thing you know,
some fucking government somewhere in the
world.
I mean,
Shit.
You think Iran wasn't interested in that
or what?
Maybe North Korea.
Certainly any,
any fucking world power would want that
weapon.
That's a great weapon outside of the
fact that it ends up.
We'll see.
You know,
biological weapons,
biological weapons have a really.
The problem with that one is it might
not burn itself out,
but biological weapons have a distinct
advantage over nuclear weapons because
nuclear weapons destroy infrastructure,
biological weapons.
Just kill a lot of logical lens,
so if you have a nice fast moving
fucking disease that you've made that
you can drop on a city,
then you know,
fly in there three months down the road,
clean up the bodies,
you've got a city,
you know.
Fuck.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
it's better than a fucking nuclear
weapon where now you've got a nuclear
wasteland that you can't use for a long
time.
So isn't it
strange just comes down to the people
that are in control of that kind of
power?
I almost can't help but be cuts.
Right?
The only reason why you got to that
position in the first place is because
you're wanting to do this.
Well,
yeah.
You ended up.
Yeah.
If you're,
if you're one of those guys pushing
these buttons,
you,
you've always wanted to do this.
Yeah.
And it puts us in a real bind man,
because it doesn't represent us.
It doesn't represent us,
represent any of us,
but even if let's say we spread it,
let's say somehow it spreads through and
all of a sudden like the consciousness
of like all these people who started
getting into power,
they're,
you know,
people who are like coming,
like people who are coming into power.
We didn't have more openminded Internet
ideology of how the world works and
let's say that just the whole of our
government suddenly turns into like the
smartest fucking people on.
Forgive me for saying this.
The smartest people on reddit are now
running the United States government.
All of a sudden that's the country would
be perfect.
Fucking.
That'd be perfect.
There'd be like,
no dude.
If the intranet ran the world,
the world would be beautiful.
There will be incredible wine because
the Internet is the voice of the people.
Really the only voice of the people.
It's the only voice we all
have there.
The only way they're the breaking news
stories of be like cute cat pictures and
sucking it the.
But here's the problem.
If that happened in this country and
let's say happened in Europe and let's
say it happened and parts of a parts of
Asia still these pockets,
all you need is like two or three
fucking pockets of people who are
worshiping some mythological entity that
they think is a hates gay people and
wants women to wear a fucking weird shit
or thinks it's okay to like lash people
are,
I think,
I don't remember which country was.
I think some countries just as executed
someone for.
I think it might've been Iran,
but that could be propaganda.
Who knows?
I don't know,
but apparently someone.
They executed a guy for coming up with a
program that allows people to download
porn.
Yes.
Now if you just have a few of these
psychopaths out there,
they can ruin the whole fucking party.
Oh my God.
It's like the earth right now has the
potential to turn into an awesome party,
but you know that thing that happens
when two dicks roll into a party,
like two Weirdos that nobody invited or
like all of a sudden start fucking
drinking too much and like trying to
pick fights.
That's what we have on a planetary scale
right now,
but then,
but the people they're becoming,
it used to be it was mostly psychos at
the party.
Now it's getting to be where there's
more and more cool people at the party
and we got to figure out how to get the
dicks out of the house.
That's where we're at right now.
Let's get these assholes out here to do
is we've got to convert the Dicks,
convert whatever dicks that can be
converted,
convert them to be cool human being.
Let them know that to be nice,
to be able feels good for you too,
and it's the best way to communicate
with people.
Be Nice to everybody,
pump your friends up,
help each other out.
Be Cool with each other,
support each other.
Look,
look,
look out for each other.
Develop a community of people that are
going to give them all mushrooms.
Don't teach you.
Why not?
Why you calling on my game,
kid,
there's a thread on mixed martial
arts.com.
One of them says,
why is Joe Rogan so in a mushrooms?
Could you see that thing I tweeted
today?
Obviously written by someone who hasn't
done mushrooms,
right?
Or the Das that you've never done
mushrooms.
Come on silly.
You see that thing I tweeted today?
Uh,
it's kind of old.
I've known about it for whereby they
found evidence to help mushrooms.
Helping depression.
Yeah.
I did see that.
Look,
in this day and age,
you know,
what they should be doing with mushrooms
is studying them.
They should have,
they should be absolutely
decriminalized.
They have no one's dying from mushrooms.
Okay?
What people are doing,
they're freaking out.
One of the reasons why they're freaking
out because life is fucking crazy enough
as it is.
And a lot of times you're holding a
billion things in the back of your head
that you're trying to fight off.
I don't want to remember.
Or You want to pretend you did a better
thing that you really didn't take those
mushrooms and you're ugly truth.
They just thrown into your face like,
like diarrhea from the horse,
just blah all over you.
That's what.
It's just like your reality and that's a
bad trip.
That's not a bad trip.
Does it trip?
You needed it there.
There are no bad trips,
Joe.
The only difficult trips.
Difficult challenging trips.
That's the idea.
You've got to remove the.
I heard that.
That's less.
You overdose.
What I did was a bad job.
There's nothing wrong with Brian.
It's sort of like if you've got jet fuel
and you shoved it into someone's Prius,
they'd be like,
what the fuck is this in here for?
We're not working.
Right.
We just don't like I couldn't walk
Duncan.
I was following.
My feet would not work.
We don't have that.
Then you'd have to be like Shaquille
O'Neal to handle that,
but in this super society or talking
about nine slash 11 for bad trips,
like seven slash 11,
if you're having a bad trip,
call it and be like,
I'm fucking freaking out.
I can't feel my feet.
And then they could,
you know that they could send over some
fucking cool.
Well the real problem is we,
we're,
we're great when we could communicate
directly with each other,
but when we band together in big groups
and then we can't communicate,
we get too far away from each other.
Then we just start getting dickie with
the people that are the furthest away,
like,
fuck them,
man.
I'm taking their shit.
They're owned by where the good water is
and you know that.
That's where the lack of it,
that the fact that you don't feel all
these other people.
I think it's an evolving entity.
That's what I think.
I think the human organism is some crazy
technology inventing,
evolving organism.
I think that the invention of technology
though I think is like the whole reason
why we're here.
I think what we're all doing as standup
comedians and as nurses and doctors and
we are all supporting the system that
keeps alive.
The people that make the awesome shit.
We're just going to find out that we are
technology.
That's when you die.
You're like,
oh,
I get it.
We're the caterpillar.
That becomes the butterfly.
We are working towards the invention of
this ultimate technology.
We just don't see it that way.
We think of our lives is I've got to get
my shit together and I've got to get my
yoga.
You know,
when I get to yoga,
I'm there.
I'm home.
I am centered,
you know,
you're just trying to make up for the
fact that you know,
you've got some weird situation where
your husband doesn't fuck anymore.
Let's be realistic.
You're getting all crazy with your
crystals because you ain't get no good
dick with them.
Chris Crazy with your crystals.
But at the end of the day I have a
feeling that the whole thing might be in
just so we keep
buying cooler shit and this weird
complex social order that we have is all
just fucking the ripples and waves of
reality.
But the whole thing is pushing towards
more improved.
No.
Yeah.
Pushes towards innovation.
Like look at what's happening right now
with Sopa and Pipa and what you're
seeing is a right now technology has
surpassed,
has their past government and it's
surpassed the control mechanisms that
are in place in like the entertainment
industry to monetize their product.
They have to innovate a new way.
They have to go
the vote on shit online.
That's what it should be.
It should be.
You log in,
you have a fucking email address.
You know,
it's Duncan trussell at the United
States of America Dot Com and you
fucking log in and you get to vote,
period.
That's how it should all be done.
Yeah,
keep the system secure.
Don't be an asshole.
Don't abuse it.
Let's find out what people really want
that you know,
that's the future.
It would be happy
down.
I know that some dude hacked UFC.com
this week.
I wanted to find out something
and one of the upcoming match.
So I don't want you to be motherfucking
kidding me.
Some little Weirdo dude made this cool.
It was actually kind of a cool,
weird picture that you would love.
It was like a Hitler with a big crazy
giant eyes.
Did you see it?
Yeah.
But you know,
it's a redirect.
Is that A.
is that as just redecorate?
Why do you like to do a site?
Because it's so Sopa the
UFC supports the,
uh,
the,
the online piracy thing.
Why?
Why did they did they must not
understand it that well.
Every media companies doing it because
that's what it's for because they're,
they're scared.
You know what it is,
man,
it's like you got this fucking problem.
People are afraid of afraid to speak up,
and a lot of people agreed on this damn
thing and now the truth is coming out
about the way it works and people are
afraid to speak.
I don't know enough about it,
but I'm going to see them this weekend.
I'm going to ask them what it's all
about.
I don't understand you,
so I'm sure there'll be able to explain
it.
You see Dana Dane as a tweets during
when all this was happening.
He's was like,
I don't give a shit.
Yeah,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He's like,
I'm not eating.
That's what he said.
He goes,
I'm not Ebay,
lol.
He goes up and down the website
business.
I'm in the flight business.
You could not have the guy running that
day.
You cannot have a better guy.
That guy's a cool Dana White Shit.
Oh,
he was.
I Dunno man.
He wants to be high with his employees.
You don't have to smoke.
Yes we do.
We're going to do a podcast.
No,
he doesn't.
We don't have to smoke.
When Danny would do it,
we
could have them for sure.
We just want to tell him.
I don't know if there's a lot of shit.
He couldn't talk about it.
Now it's big time.
Big Time with Fox.
Fox,
Fox.
Fight this weekend and you don't give a
fuck.
So I'll just talk about it amongst
myself.
I'm very excited.
Wait,
the Oh,
is that you have seen this week?
I know that.
I see.
Yeah.
It's a Damien Maia versus this kid Chris
Weidman.
He's just a bad ass wrestler from New
York.
Fucking kids.
A beast.
He's like one of those up and coming
guys strangling,
putting people to sleep,
taking people down,
smashing like veterans and he's taken on
that.
Damien Maia Jujitsu wizard.
That's how bad ass fight.
You know what shocking about the UFC man
that I never.
You don't see unless you come to like
alive.
UFC seeing somebody get choked out up
close is fucking disturbing,
man.
It's awesome.
But man,
when you see that fucking,
it's like.
It's like watching somebody with like,
I don't know,
the gardening,
she just.
It just clamps down.
It's like watching a clamp just smashed
someone's wind pipe.
It seems like they can't live after
that.
It seems like you destroy their neck.
Yeah.
You feel like it,
but no dudes come right back.
Judge,
you see that USC has the xbox app now
where you can just watch live UFC on
xbox.
You can sit there and pay per view,
but through xbox.
How much is it?
The charger?
Xbox,
is that what?
Yeah,
that's sweet.
They're going to do it and they're doing
them in movie theaters as well.
They've done it before I moved here.
That would be fucking cool.
But you know,
checkouts physiologically,
not that bad for your body.
Head impact is bad.
Yeah.
Hen impact they're finding out is,
you know,
you got to limit the amount of times you
get hit.
That's why for a fighter it's really
important to know what to hang it up.
There's a certain amount of shots and
after that you should really.
You should.
You know,
I know you still like to do it,
but you got to think about your feet.
Who decides this is the.
Does the.
Is it always in that decision at the
fighter in the UFC?
Ultimately it has to be the decision of
the fighter unless someone owns him,
unless he's a slave.
But as an organization,
if you kind of know a guy in the
organization,
if the UFC decided that someone should
be fighting for them,
that doesn't keep them from fighting,
they'll go somewhere else.
I mean the,
the UFC,
you know,
does offer advice to guys and they,
they,
you know,
they care very much for their fighters.
They have like,
you know,
like chocolate l,
they gave him a great job and part of
the reason was they didn't want him to
fight anymore.
He had this amazing career,
but when it's over,
it's over.
And you know,
they,
they had one last fight.
He lost that.
They said,
all right,
you're right.
I'm just going to settle in.
And they got an awesome cushy desk job
and he travels around and like
represents the UFC.
And the beauty of that is it's like they
took care of them.
They're like,
they pull them,
you know what I mean?
Like they said,
look,
this is,
this is it,
this is time.
Let's,
let's just settle the fuck down.
You know,
let's,
let's move on to the next stage of life.
You're an author,
you're a bad motherfucker.
He'll be a bad motherfucker business.
He'll be a bad motherfucker to anything.
He wants to do a certain point in time,
you know,
it's good to have somebody cares for you
that comes in and steps in.
And that's what Dana did.
Dana like totally hooked,
chuck up.
You know,
chuck was with him from the beginning.
They were there,
they were together at the beginning and
he's taken care of.
Um,
and it's,
it's awesome.
It's awesome to see that.
And it's awesome to see a guy who knows,
you know what,
this is a smart thing to do.
I'm just going to step away because it's
so hard for fighters.
Man.
That moment of the moment of competition
is so intense and so extreme and
victory,
you know,
I've been there while Chuck Liddell won
like some big,
big fights.
I was like right there during the Hay
day when he was in his prime man and
having been and having seen that,
if you could ever do that ever,
you could ever do that,
you would want to keep doing it.
You would just be convinced,
I'm just going to go one more time.
I'm going to keep doing it.
It's amazing that he could ever stop
because it's such a rush for them.
I watched him knock these down.
I watched him knock Randy coture out
twice.
She is flatlining guys with these
punches.
It was crazy and running around.
He was the scariest fucking guy on the
planet for like a few years.
Man.
He was terrifying when he was just
running shit in the UFC when he was in
his true athletic peak.
That must have been an amazing feeling.
It must've been.
That life must have been so crazy and
exciting.
You're stepping into a cage against the
most ferocious guys on the planet and
you're smashing them,
smashing them in front of the whole
world.
You know?
I mean,
he's.
His career was incredible man.
Just fucking incredible knockouts.
The Bible,
Lou knockouts,
but he was just a beast man when he was,
when Chuck Liddell was on,
on top when he was at his best man,
one of the most exciting guys of all
time.
So for that guy,
you know,
it's,
it's probably real hard.
Jesus.
Just accept giddy up in the morning
listening to the quiet of your yard as
you walk towards your fucking newspaper,
that sitting in your front porch and
you're looking out there and just people
are mowing their lawn.
You start shadow box.
You start going.
Maybe just one more fight.
Alright,
you get bored?
Yeah,
back in there.
I want to feel a fucking rush.
You want to,
you know,
it's hard for those guys.
It's very hard.
It's an incredibly difficult transition.
I experienced it in the most minute of
levels,
you know,
just tight window and kickboxing.
But when I,
when I stopped fighting,
when I was like 20,
21 or 22 was my last fights,
I,
I just fucking.
It's,
it's a,
it's a weird thing.
It's a hard decision to either feeling,
man.
I,
I get that feeling now that it gets
boring.
I get that feeling when I delete
starcraft for Michael,
it's you.
The real problem with me,
when I was a kid doing martial arts is
worried about two things.
One,
you couldn't make any money.
There was no money in I kickboxing.
It's nothing back then does.
She couldn't even kickbox and
Massachusetts,
you'd have to drive to Rhode island like
we couldn't.
It was weird.
You could fight in full contact.
Taekwondo matches in Massachusetts,
but you couldn't kick box.
You had to go to Rhode Island for that
and they didn't even have more.
Tyler,
it was just like,
it was a,
it was a mess.
And then there's the brain damage issue,
brain damage,
which is always a concern.
I was always thinking about that because
I knew I was like,
you know,
um,
I did not do very well in school,
but because I did not want to pay
attention,
I was just really distracted kid.
I'm sure if I was with the wrong
parents,
they would have drugged me.
Especially today.
Yeah,
it was like super distracted,
you know,
but I read a lot of Shit and you know,
go being like a young kid and not like
what the fuck is going on with the world
and trying to figure things out and
trying to like read as much as you can
to try to piece it together yourself.
This is a very bizarre place to be.
Yeah.
A lot of us get there,
right?
A lot of people that we know came from a
place where when they were really young
they were like,
what the fuck is going on with the
world?
How old do you think you were when you
had your first?
Oh,
I think my parents might be fucking
crazy thought.
Were you like,
these people are in charge of telling me
what to do.
This is nonsense.
You make you,
you're talking crazy talk here.
It happens.
It happened for me the first time that I
took a lsd a and maybe before that,
but when I took Lsd,
I,
when I took lsd for the first time,
I can remember when,
whenever you take Lsd,
especially,
you know,
I mean,
when I took Lsd,
what worries do I have?
I'm in fucking high school.
There's no,
there's nothing in it.
There's nothing to.
There's no demons to come swimming out
of my brain and taunt me with like all
the myriad of things you get when you're
older.
There's fucking nothing we just opened.
I'm,
I might be upset because like I said,
a cheerleader that came over to my
house.
I couldn't figure out how to kiss her.
Maybe that's like the biggest problem
I'm having at the time.
So,
but I,
you know,
at that time when I did it for the first
time and had that initial experience,
you know,
when you go back to your parents who've
never taken it,
and if you mentioned to them that you'd
even taken it,
they might want to put you in a drug
rehab or they think you're insane or
they think you're getting down the wrong
track,
you're forced into this place of like,
fuck man,
I can't,
I,
you,
you guys don't even,
you don't even know you.
You don't even understand this new way
of experiencing life.
You know,
so.
And I think there's a lot of people who
spend their whole lives never knowing
that you don't have to take psychedelics
to get to that place.
There's other ways to get to that place.
But yeah,
it's a very strange thing.
And those people who never get to that
place,
they're the ones who are,
a lot of them are,
are in control.
Right.
So your life took an inexorable change
when you did acid.
That was the point where you look back
and you said,
this is the point where I went off into
this direction.
Um,
well,
I know I'd say that the,
the,
that,
that taking acid started with a series
of like books.
It started with contact with like,
you know,
the whole weirdness.
My whole weird weirdness started with,
or as I recall,
it started with me coming upon this book
that my mom had called Raja Yoga by Yogi
raw mature Rocka,
who by the way,
it was never a Yogi which just some
English mistake and lied about being a
Yogi,
but is a fascinating story.
But the book,
you know,
that was the first time I'd ever read
the idea that you're there,
that you're an observer observing
yourself,
that you,
you aren't necessarily the,
you,
that you think the,
that can be observed is not you.
You're the observer state.
The mindfulness,
the watch or that's when I,
that's the first time I'd come upon the
idea of what's that's called the altman.
The thing that observes yourself.
You know,
when you know someone will say,
I'm really mad right now.
The moment you say I'm mad,
you're creating a distinction,
you know,
between the thing that's observing that
you're mad and the thing that's mad,
so that observer,
that watcher,
that's the thing that,
that mindfulness is what,
you know,
throughout my whole life,
I try to,
you know,
go into that place of observing myself
rather than being the thing and it's a
game that you can play and it really is
quite helpful with a variety of,
of problems,
especially if you get really angry.
If you get really angry and you can stop
yourself and just watch and there's
tools you can use in that book.
I remember it said as you walk around,
start thinking he is walking.
That was one of the tools,
like it's in a book and you're a
character in a book.
So when you're going around you're like,
you know,
right now he's doing a podcast right
now.
He is talking and so that's,
these are,
these are activities designed to create
this.
Like the watcher,
the state of presence of watching.
So that started it.
That led me to like,
you know,
I,
and then I found out about,
you know,
I,
I think I read the electric koolaid acid
test,
you know,
about fucking Ken Kesey and the merry
pranksters blasting themselves on acid
and going to the world's fair in a bus.
And then I read that shit.
I remember.
Wait,
I'll tell you that.
I'll stop this weird,
weird rant.
I remember now.
Fucking film strip.
That's what it started in my head.
I think I was in fourth grade and they
showed us a drug film strip.
Remember film strips fucking popped up.
This guy like it caught.
There's a guy I still remember.
It's a guy in it.
It's a guy in a fucking empty apartment
and he's curled against the law in the
fetal position and it's an lsd and it
looks terrible.
And then the narrator says,
Lsd can make you experience
hallucinations.
You can see dragons.
And I remember him saying,
you could see drag.
And I'm like,
I want to see it.
Sounds awesome.
Fuck the empty apartment in the fetal
position.
I'll figure it out.
So that guy's a pussy.
What are you crying?
So I drag a little bit.
It's a gas
and that was,
that.
Put it in my head is like,
well,
you know,
I,
I think that that's an interesting thing
to explore,
but
yeah,
that's hilarious.
So you think that you were like to
Dunkin's like Duncan one and Duncan to
like Dunkin one is like regular Dunkin
growing up,
innocent boy.
Sure.
Boom.
Psychedelics.
And then Duncan to two point.
Oh
yeah,
yeah.
There's definitely a dunk into that.
That happened.
I'd say.
And then that,
that Duncan to change too man,
because you know as you get older,
the best thing that there's two great.
The best thing that can happen to you as
you get knocked off track,
that's the best thing that can happen to
you in general because generally the
track you're on has been set for you by
people who never got off their track.
You end up,
you end up the child of someone who
decided to have you in their twenties,
21,
22.
They're not going to know a lot of
stuff.
They're not going to understand the
universe that much unless they were like
came from a really good family of artist
are intelligent people.
Chances are they're scared,
hungry,
desperate,
angry.
They don't want to be in the
relationship anymore.
They don't want to be monogamous
anymore.
The idea of non monogamy to them might
just seem insane.
Like who the fuck knows,
but you're born into that planet.
Your.
That's the atmosphere you're born into.
That's what you're breathing when you're
first born and that can set you on a
weird path and that's a very sad path
that you can get on.
And so hopefully if you're lucky,
you'll come across somebody who knocks
you off that fucking path.
You know?
I remember the guy who hooked me up with
acid.
I remember sitting in the theater of my
school because I was taking.
I was at drama nerd and I sitting in the
theater of my school next to this guy,
so the two next to this guy,
Brad,
and I remember seeing an eye and we're
talking and he mentioned tripping on Lsd
and I'm like,
what is like,
oh yeah,
I took acid over the weekend.
I'm like,
well,
why?
You can get acid
the life,
the life of somebody must animate this.
Somebody the police.
I know your folks out there that animate
shit.
You got to animate this.
That,
that moment took me to.
And this is really weird.
Tell me what the first trip was like.
I love to.
The first trip was,
uh,
it was white blotter,
a white blotter paper.
I don't,
it was just white blotter,
a little p for somehow if you don't know
this,
uh,
lsd gets put on sheets that looked like
blotter paper and sometimes they have
designed,
sometimes they don't,
but the name is always a reference to
usually as a reference to the design on
the sheet.
So,
uh,
you know,
purple,
Jesus,
White Blotter of lips,
you know,
there's a million different names for
the different types of acid,
but,
so this is just white unit is what it
was,
but it was really good and I can
remember I took it and you have to,
you know,
it takes 30 to 45 minutes sometimes
longer for it to kick in.
I still remember I was sitting in my
friend's trailer in a trailer park in
North Carolina sitting in an empty
bathtub,
like when it like an empty Jacuzzi tub
that was in this trailer and I'm sitting
there and they're watching star wars and
I'm sitting in this bathtub and all of a
sudden the greatest,
it's the greatest feeling just started
going through my legs and up into my
body and it was a fucking sword fight.
It was a light Saber fight when I'm
listening to that.
But all of a sudden now the sounds
echoey,
like someone's turned an echo up on it.
So I was like,
man,
well my parents kind of bouncing around.
It's beautiful and I feel so fucking
good.
Started laughing.
It seems so funny.
Then I went outside and lay in the
grass.
I'm staring at the sky.
Everything's beautiful trails.
You put your hand in front of your face
and it's just this rainbow of hands
drifting in front of your face.
Everything's breathing.
Then my friends come running out because
they knew this is the first time I was
tripping and they all start jumping over
me.
They're like jumping over me as I'm
laying there and they're laughing and
we're all fucking laughing and it's just
perfect.
Then I remember they pulled their cock
out.
That's when they pulled that.
Y'all started talking.
We fucked and fucked and then a dog came
by and we grabbed the dog and started
fucking the dog.
No,
no,
no.
It was beautiful.
Spirit of acid is very now.
Yeah.
There was no fucking happening.
There was a lot of like laughing.
I remember going into my friend Shitty
high school car in like sitting in,
like pulling the seat back and looking
at the ceiling and I'm looking at the
ceiling and it's fucking hieroglyphics
or some kind of like ancient writing,
you know?
I don't even think I knew what Sanskrit
was at the time,
but I probably be like,
oh,
I'm seeing Sanskrit.
Some kind of runes are glyphs all over
my friend's car that she's kind of
breathing and warping and it's just
beautiful.
So yeah,
that was the,
that was the first time.
And once you've had that experience,
how do you go back to a world?
A normal kind of world?
First time I ever did acid.
I've,
I've told you this before.
I met Kurt cobain.
How crazy was that?
Whoa.
Wow.
The story
again.
I think I died this night by the way.
I have just been very that no,
that this is what made me think of a
theory that like every time you die you
don't know that you die,
but then you left this road and everyone
else in this other parallel road,
you know,
they think you die.
Like you know the funeral.
And this is where I thought this was the
first time I did ask that me and my
girlfriend at the time,
that was Marissa.
We went to go see.
We went to go see nirvana and she had an
acid and I,
I've never done acid before.
She goes,
let's do acid and cedar vinyl.
So we took acid and the opening band was
on which,
which is some Asian band that just
screamed the whole time and it was like,
you know,
it's kind of like annoying.
So I was sitting next to the side of the
stage and Kurt cobain comes around the
corner and just comes out and it was
really dark so no one could see it and
he's just standing right next to me.
I look over,
I'm like,
oh my fucking God,
it's Kurt cobain.
And I was like,
Hey,
what's up?
And he goes,
hey,
you weren't cheeto.
And he held out his bag and I'm like,
yeah.
And so I held on the cheeto and then
suddenly he just like,
somebody goes,
oh Kurt.
And then he just like throws all the
cheetos out in the crowd and then it
returns back backstage.
I'm holding this cheeto and I'm like
through the cheetos and the crowd,
get a bag of cheetos that he was eating
for him.
He just threw it at the crowd.
He just threw cheetos everywhere.
I mean it was.
This is like a mosh pit in Dayton,
Ohio side of the stage,
like a rock club,
you know,
Harry arena,
I think it was
a fucking video of Dana white getting in
a mosh pit.
Yeah.
He went into a rage rage against the
machine concert.
Motherfucker got into mosh pit.
She got security guards looking out for
him and he jumped to the mosque.
So I took this cheeto and I put it in my
pocket.
Like I'm like,
I'm going to save this Cheeto,
you know?
And then I start tripping really hard
and had an amazing concert on the way
home.
We're driving and we go by in like,
I'm driving it and this is a
thunderstorm of rain.
I'm still tripping,
tripping,
tripping on acid as responsible
citizens.
And then this is even better.
And I swear to God that you could ask
her.
I'm not gonna say who she is on here,
but we started fucking while I was
driving in the rain storm on asset for
my first time fucking.
And that's where I think I died the
first time,
one of the first times I died.
It might be you guys
this.
Isn't that a theory that you said to me
once?
Yeah.
It's the idea that when you die,
I think.
Yeah,
you're the one.
You've said that before.
Yeah.
It's just that.
It's like a car.
It's a multiverse idea.
The idea is you're a fucking.
You know what?
Your eternal being,
you are an eternal being.
Your body is a frequent.
It's like a radio.
That's the tunes you in.
Tune into your specific personality in
and the moment you die,
that radio frequency pops into something
else.
So there's no death.
There's no you're not.
It's not like you die and there's
nothing there.
Empty emptiness.
And it's not like you die and you're
born as a baby and get to start over
again.
It's like something happens.
You're driving down the street and
you're like,
man,
why is that guy in my?
And then all of a sudden you open your
eyes and you're going to work,
going to work.
And like man,
as a weird dream.
And then you start that life again,
it goes on forever like that,
that the horrible idea,
especially horrible to bring it up to
anybody who's had poor fortune in this
life is to somehow or another connected
with past lives.
You know,
when you've ever heard someone say that
like,
Oh,
you must have been a real fuck head in
his past life.
And it's like,
wow,
like,
what are you real?
Are you sure?
You sure could it just not be a roll of
the dice?
And maybe part of your Karma is
recognizing that.
I think that,
yeah,
that's why I like the uh,
you know,
a Buddha,
Buddha said,
don't,
don't think about the afterlife so much.
I think even Christ said,
I am the god of the living,
not the god of the dead.
The idea being that with a voice,
it's a good.
I think real spiritual masters always
tend to try to bring people back into
the present moment because it's like,
you know what?
The president has everything.
I know when Shit goes wrong in my life,
I know why it went wrong.
I don't have to go back to when I was a
fryer in the 18 hundreds and like fisted
a fucking,
you know none.
I know that if shit's going wrong right
now,
generally it's like because I'm fucking
up now.
It's good for and people can get lost.
People can start blaming their,
their Karma or where they're at right
now.
I'm past lives and it puts him in this
place of stupid hopelessness and they
don't do the things they need to do
right now to get to a better place.
Praise Jesus.
Praise the Lord because I hear so many
fucking say his name.
So many simple things you could do,
man.
All you at.
Here's what you have to do.
This is my new theory.
Identify the vampire in your life.
Find the vampire,
identify the parasite.
It doesn't have to be that you have
parasites in life.
It is possible.
You could have gotten lucky and there's
no parasites and you get off groovy.
Sure.
No,
I'm not saying everyone's got one,
but if you got one,
if you're walking around with those
fucking vampire blues,
you've got the fucking heavy heart and
you can't feel happy and you feel bad.
There may be an action that you need to
take that you're afraid to take.
That's the vampire and you've got to
fucking not even a person.
Oh No,
I mean it's a situation.
A vampire in your life.
Find a life sucking situation that
you're afraid to kill,
and the reason I say vampires because
vampire is only go where they're invited
and generally the situation that you're
in,
you invited it in,
you invited this thing into your life
and now it's sucking your life energy in
your blood and your happiness away.
Don't it needs.
A lot of times you'll try to believe
you'll try to convince yourself that
this thing is not a vampire,
but in your heart,
you know you're a servant to a fucking
bloodsucker urn felt this thing is like
sucking your life as it's away.
Sometimes it's doing it with a trade.
Quite often there'll be a bad trade.
You'll be,
you know,
whatever the situation you're in and
you'll,
you'll feel like you're in this
situation.
You know,
it's worth it.
It's kind of bad,
but it's totally worth it.
This happens with jobs quite often,
you know,
or you're like,
well,
you know,
but that's good enough.
That's the vampire you gotta take a
fucking stake and drive it into.
It's hard to.
How do you kill a vampire?
Two ways.
Direct Action.
You don't kill a vampire by like making
up with a vampire.
You don't kill a vampire by like having
a sit down and talk with a vampire.
You're not going to be able to like,
you know,
make friends with the vampire.
There's two ways to kill a vampire.
One,
you fucking put a stake in its heart.
The other one is light,
sunlight,
truth,
light.
That is the greatest metaphor of all
time.
You shine the light of truth onto the
situation,
fearlessly analyze it and then you'll
destroy it.
You know,
because if you really allow yourself,
if you could act,
you gotta add the real problem with
people is not recognizing the enemy.
It's acting on that enemy.
That's the real problem,
and that enemy being personal,
your personal demons,
your your personal jihad.
That's a personal issue.
You got to fight the beast and it's in
the end.
You know what I mean?
It's like everybody's beast.
Different.
Chapter two of the Bhagavad Gita,
Arginine,
dejection.
Arginine has drawn between these two
forces.
He does not want to fight.
He drops his bow and God says to him,
you've got to rise to the fight.
Fight.
You're a warrior.
This is what you're here for.
Fight,
fight.
It's,
it's better to die.
It's better to die in a righteous
battle.
Then goes skulking off into the fucking
woods and be a beggar.
It's better to fucking do what you do on
your award or you got to fucking do it.
Man.
It fucking sucks.
When you're drunk and you want to throw
up and you try to not make yourself
throw up,
just throw up.
You'll feel better.
You'll feel better in the end when
you're puking,
it's gonna suck because you're helpless
and you can't breathe.
Go through it,
man.
Fucking jab a fucking knife into the
foot.
Not Literally of course,
but yeah,
you got to act and you got to make the
big fucking decisions sometimes and it's
scary.
If it wasn't scary,
it wouldn't be worth anything.
Yeah.
For some people it's almost like they
don't know how to start.
They know that there's action that they
need to take in their life,
but they're paralyzed trying to think
about it,
trying to figure out how to start and
they can never gather up the courage to
get away.
It's like a lot of people stay in
abusive relationships.
They don't.
They don't have the courage to lead
exactly because it's scary and it and it
and it seems like it,
you know,
there's so many things that people will,
like,
ideas people will create.
They'll keep you trapped and whatever.
Prison,
urine.
It's very similar to and not.
I mean what you're talking about in the
UFC with these fucking fighters,
this is a visual representation of what
anyone can do in their life,
but you're not getting.
Maybe not all of us are going to get,
obviously be world class fighters,
the inner ring in front of the entire
planet and fucking knock someone out,
but you have in your life right now,
if you haven't already done this,
there is.
You have the chance to be heroic.
You have the ability right now to make a
heroic act.
They could kill you.
That's the thing.
These actions,
it's not always guaranteed that because
you do the right thing,
you're going to end up in a great place.
You might end up fucked.
You might end up,
you might end up temporarily in a
homeless or you might end up temporarily
jobless.
If there wasn't risk associated with it,
you would have already done it.
That's the point.
You know,
if there wasn't a risk associated with
it wouldn't be worth anything.
You know,
if Mount fucking Himalaya is we're,
you know,
a little green grass covered hill and
apart,
nobody takes pictures of them at the
top.
Putting a flag into what is the danger.
Makes it heroic,
you know?
So sometimes you just have to fucking.
I sound like Tony Robbins.
Take the leap.
Kill the vampire in your life.
Kill the vampire.
You'll have is a brilliant speech.
Dude.
You're,
you're dead,
right?
I thought I stopped it because I'm like,
not everybody has a bad person in your
life,
but I didn't know that.
That's where your main,
that's you're absolutely dead.
Right.
You know,
I,
I always say that you know,
the energy vampires that you have in
your life,
are you really your number one enemy?
They keep you from enjoying good times.
You know,
there's,
everybody knows I one person will,
you settle down.
You're like,
oh,
finally I can fucking relax.
And you turn on the television and then
someone for whatever fucking reason will
decide that they have to talk to you now
and they want to get angry at you.
Now you know,
it could be a guy or girl,
whoever the fuck it is,
it's one person that wants to,
they want to have power over you or
another and they want to stop you from
doing what you want to do.
Like there are people that have issues
in relationships because one of the
persons and then one of the people in
the relationship has some sort of a
transparent issue with the other person
and what they try to do is they try to
control that person from doing things
that they want to do.
Anytime the guy wants to go play,
play a basketball or something like
that,
they come up with a reason why now is
the time I would really like you to take
me shopping.
Or now it's time.
It's almost like they want to see if
they can drag you away from the thing
that you like to do,
thus proving that they're the most
important thing in your life.
And you know what man,
that's fucking sad.
Well,
you know what it is.
It's instincts.
This is how girls behave if you don't
keep the pimp hand strong and that's a
fact.
That's a fact.
The only reason why girls get away with
stuff like that is because guys let them
get away with it.
Just like,
you know,
the real issue with guys being douche
bags to girls of course,
is the physical violence issue.
It's not fair.
It's not fair if you're fucking two
chicks getting into fight with each
other,
you know,
two lesbians and you basically the same
size,
you know,
hey,
I don't want you to fight,
but you know,
I don't know why you're fighting,
but hopefully you got a good reason.
But it's not a mugging.
It's not a man beating up a woman.
They're so physical fights are
completely out of the question either.
So,
and then what else is left?
What else is left?
Trying to explain each other to each
other,
you know,
arguing with each other,
trying to piece it all together would
not understanding their side at all.
You know,
we,
we certainly have to protect people from
that kind of violence.
Right?
Yeah.
And that's,
you know,
that's,
that's one of the ways that we know that
there's some sort of a,
a weird disconnect between what we're
capable of and the way we currently
behave like as a human race.
The fact that it's even possible that we
have a real issue with men beating the
fuck out of women.
Like that's a real issue when women who
get in relationships and get beat up.
That's terrifying.
That's scary shit.
Yeah,
it's scary.
It was a girl that I dated when I was in
high school and she was really crazy and
she was just,
uh,
just,
she had like super strict Catholic
parents and she,
she was really pretty and she was just
nuts,
man.
And we,
we,
we didn't see each other for years.
And then one time I was a,
at this might not even been years,
maybe eight months,
I might be exaggerating,
but I hadn't seen her in a long time.
When you're 17 years old,
six months might as well be fucking
years.
I mean,
things are accelerating.
Either graduated from high school and,
you know what I mean?
Um,
and I met her and she was telling me
that she had this new boyfriend that hit
her and that she liked.
It was the craziest conversation.
And I was like,
whoa.
And first of all,
I was thinking,
thank God I never hit her because what
have I liked it too?
What if you know you,
you know what if you date a girl and she
would totally start fights and totally
do shit to Piss me off.
But I never thought you wanted to get
like,
well I never,
you can't hit a girl.
Just it's,
it's silly face or hit in the vagina to
get smacked.
She'd like to get in the face.
She'd like to get rocked.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
But she was telling me this
understanding.
No,
she was not rationalizing or you're
talking about.
She was being really honest with me.
She was like,
I'm so confused.
I wasn't a dumb girl.
No,
no,
no.
Talking about a dude.
Basically just smacking her around and
fucking her like really rough and beat
her up.
Some girls actually like that.
There's like a weird thing in them.
That one.
I mean obviously they don't want to get
injured,
but they want to get roughed up.
They want to just get hair pulling and
smacked him.
And this girl was like into getting
smacked.
It was like really crazy to hear.
I was like,
I didn't know what to say.
I'm like,
you know what?
I said to her,
I said,
listen,
you can only get hit so many times in
the hand before you get brain damage.
Okay.
You really have to consider that.
Sounds like that already have said how
this guy's fucking you all the time and
every time he's fucking you,
he's hitting you in the head.
I'm like,
do you have headaches?
I started asking her things.
I asked fighters get headaches,
sleep at night.
Like I'm a brain doctor or some shit.
I was like,
you can't let that do hit you in the
head.
Right?
Don't let.
But if for whatever reason,
like turned her on,
can you imagine having to tell someone
you shouldn't let that guy hit you in
the hat man,
because you know what's confusing is
guys can be like super loving after they
do it because they feel terrible and
then they're like really affectionate.
Yeah.
They're really affectionate with.
Some of them aren't even that,
you know,
but with a lot of people that are the
ones that like get drunk and blame it on
getting drunk and that's where they're
abusing each other
world out there and there's a lot of sad
homes in America.
There's a lot of sad,
sad.
It's just broken peep,
reality broken,
people interacting with each other that
it's broken.
People interact with each other.
All could be fixed with mushrooms,
with the Duncan Trussell,
shamonic institute of America to correct
all of these problems with plants.
That'd be great.
And the wisdom of the indigenous peoples
of the Amazon rain forest,
combination of chanting and flashlights.
We will.
Well,
the fleshlight uses mandatory when
you're meditating at my restaurant
because I don't want anybody horny.
I don't want like why you're in there
and you're,
you know,
you're supposed to be doing your alms.
You're thinking about getting your dick
sucked.
You know what man,
you know,
like the way,
like what did I read this great
autobiography of Timothy Leary and they
were talking about,
I can't remember the name of the famous
house that he lived at,
but where there were all tripping out
and like,
while they're constantly taking lsd,
they would do this.
They were all swingers.
So there,
there'd be like guys and girls do and
what they was banging guys that were
right?
Uh,
I think.
I think so,
yeah.
I do know fast,
but I,
I,
I think Timothy leary's pretty straight.
He was always dating models and shit.
Like I think,
yeah,
but that's why America hated him.
A bunch of haters.
But what they would do is they would
like have this weird thing because what
they were trying to do is they're trying
to dissolve the react there.
They're trying to dissolve all the
fucking ego constructs of which one of
them is monogamy.
Monogamy is an ego construct where you
want to be the only person who is
fucking the person that you're with and
you and they want you to be the only
person to be fucking them.
This,
this is basic way that most people enter
into relationships,
so what these guys would do is they have
married couples and why they would do is
randomly to people would be picked a man
and a woman to go into this bowling
alley that they had and they would stay
there for like three days straight and
just take acid the whole time and they
would always end up fucking and the.
So is this idea,
but there was a lot of babies where
nobody knew who the father was for sure.
That I'm sure that happened all the
time.
Well that was Mckenna's idea was the,
an orgy hastick mushroom cultures that
existed in his really think that's kind
of a lot of it was his imagination of
what could have been possible because it
doesn't seem like you really explain
exactly what these people were doing,
you know,
10,000
years ago and chuck a towel.
He yoke and all these different places.
But he had this idea that this,
the.
They developed this sort of a orgiastic
mushroom style of,
of living.
And then people would get together and
they would just come,
you know,
so they would raise each others kids,
they would all have it all be loving
each other at all,
taking care of each other's kids.
I'm like,
wow,
that's kind of trippy.
You know,
it makes me think like,
could you live in a world like that?
I mean if it,
if that we all are just automatically
possessive of our loved ones,
our sexual partners.
You know,
your wives,
boyfriends and husbands was terrible.
Yeah.
Well yeah it does.
But it also feels great when you have
each other to count on and you have this
really cool relationship.
Know each other.
Right?
But the idea that someone like,
like you're connected,
like you,
you're not even allowed to touch and
other body like everyone else is like,
get away,
get away.
You're connected,
you're connected to the one you're
connected to.
The one thing
fields,
man,
that's it.
That's strange.
That feeling,
that inspires.
That is not a loving feeling.
It's a fucking.
No,
no.
It's because men and women have
completely different wiring.
And for a lot of women and not all of
them,
some women just want dick all around
every corner,
some women.
And that's their prerogative man.
If you're young and hot and you want
Dick around every corner,
you should be able to get it.
Like,
what does that bad when it's only good
when you fucker.
You know what I mean?
People are.
People are God damn crazy.
There really are like there's a fucking
whore.
If she was fucking you,
you'd be like,
Oh God.
So lucky dude.
We had one smile and she goes,
you want to come up to my room?
Oh,
showed us,
you know,
like how come when you score?
It's awesome.
And when she scores with other dudes,
she's a fucking.
Well,
I'll tell,
I'll tell you
why.
The reason that is is because our
descendants were fucking sexually
repressed psychopaths and we still have.
We still have that in us.
And I know there's,
that's a little of that.
But it's also that we know that girls
that are freaks like that.
It's a rare thing.
It's a weird thing.
It's like probably a weird combative
thing.
Women are getting a really shitty
position where they got to feel bad.
If you have a few guys,
and that's not fair,
and I,
and I know some of it's genetic,
but I know
well,
every relationship gets stale.
Taking out the idea of the genetic why
people want men want to reproduce with
as many women as possible.
Even if you didn't have that,
that instinctive nature.
There's still the idea that being with
one person will just get stale.
Imagine this somehow from your mind is
removed.
All the negative or weird or strange
connotations about sex.
Sex is just the physical experience of
close of oneness with another person,
so there's no.
Nothing from the ice has been putting
your head.
Now imagine eating mushrooms and all of
a sudden being in the experience of
having sex with a group of people with
zero sexual inhibitions,
with zero guilt,
just pure,
hedonistic pleasure as you sort of
missed.
I can be honest
with in terms of like a Utopian society,
but the way our world runs.
It's like my thoughts on it.
I have always been,
and my advice has always been that when
you find someone who you really enjoy
hanging out with,
hang out with them and whatever,
if you get to a point where you really
trust them and you're really honest with
each other and you're really enjoying
each other's,
find out what bothers that person.
What is it was zero genetic thing that
you have maybe that I don't have.
What is it?
You know?
Yeah,
yeah,
I don't like me in,
and if you can do that,
if you could find someone you really
sync up with and you actually enhance
each other,
then it relationships are fucking
beautiful.
The real problem is most people did not
even in the exploring their own
consciousness,
they're not into exploring their own,
the origin of their own thoughts,
that they're not really into self
examination.
They're not really into a lot of
different things that lead to sometimes
problematic conversations that you have,
especially when they have a commodity
and the commodity is that there an
attractive woman and you're in some sort
of a weird situation where there's a
master,
there's a master over you.
Penta,
and it also depends on the,
the way you get into the thing.
I mean if you look at the entry
mechanism into these things,
quite often it's purely based on
scality.
Yeah,
that's the problem is that the drug of
sex and it's really exciting and
thrilling to get to the.
I love you part as quick as possible so
the sex can get really intense,
you know?
And that is one of the things that
happens when you really love someone
like you.
You could fuck someone that you think is
hot and it's like a sexual thing and
it's,
you know,
it's really,
it's a real big turn on,
but it's not like fucking someone that's
hot that you love.
So yeah,
and that first awesome time when you're
just getting into a relationship where
the person says,
I think I'm falling in love with you and
you've been feeling that.
Holy Shit Man.
Fireworks.
It's great.
How
about for some people they'll look for
an artificial that you know,
like you can if you get lucky and you
actually do have that.
Wow,
that's so lucky.
You the stars have to align.
So many people get in situations where
the person they're with is just a little
off man,
this whatever it is,
just a little off ever.
The video that awful.
What I consider to be the most grotesque
experiment of all time where the
fucking.
They took a monkey,
a little baby monkey and they gave him a
wire or did either.
I don't even want to talk about this
disturbs me so much.
They're covered a fucking like a little
box with for.
Yeah,
and the fucking things.
Cleaning to it.
Oh See,
now here's the thing.
It's crazy.
Some people you see that some people
that a lot of people are in that
relationship where they're cleaning to
something that's not even real and they
don't even under.
They've like trick themselves into
thinking that
the real issue is the route.
The other person,
the issue is that people that are
raising these people,
the real issue is how do you.
You know,
everyone starts out neutral with w,
whatever blend of personality.
I bet almost every kid,
unless they have some serious
neurological difficulties on almost
every kid can be rendered a positive
human being by the right people.
They're surrounded by the right people.
It's like we're.
What we're doing is by putting,
we're putting the most important thing
for the resources of the human race,
the youthful people developing into
contributing members of society who can
actually add to the culture,
add to the experience,
add to the process,
and we're putting the development of our
most valuable resource in the hands of
everyone and anyone including retards,
morons,
assholes,
douchebags,
fuckheads,
everyone in between.
There's a bunch of crazy motherfuckers
shit out kids every day and you can't.
You can't say anything about it because
then you're Hitler and then you're,
you know,
you're,
you.
Are you a fan of eugenics?
Do you know how they didn't work in the
past?
The guess what else isn't working?
This overpopulation by monkeys isn't
working
well.
That's why you gotta be a bit of A.
I mean if you start waking up to
yeah,
we got to wake all these people up and
figuring out a way to re evaluate or
reevaluate will reset people's minds to
reset people's what?
Whatever it is that your operating
system is.
How,
what,
where,
where it's failing.
Well,
you,
you have to like,
you know,
sometimes you get these really fucking
flattering tweets from people who listen
as I'm like,
man,
I wish I had friends like you guys in my
hometown to talk to you.
And that's really a super sweet thing to
say,
but I always think to myself,
you know what?
Why don't you go,
why don't you go make some?
Why don't you use fucking tar turned
into it?
I know it's hard,
but I want to get out of the highest.
I don't mean just small town.
I mean,
I don't mean go make some in the sense
of light a wicker.
I don't mean.
No.
I mean no like baskets.
Now that we're not,
we know wicked.
Why don't you go?
Why don't you go,
we've a friend.
No,
I'm saying what you do is you got to be
there.
You got to be the force that maybe like
throw somebody off their track,
you know,
you might have to be the thing that does
that because my,
like the people I owe the most to are
the people who manage to fucking knocked
me off my track,
you know,
managed to like fucking bring to me
music I'd never heard before showed me
books I'd never heard before.
And then all of a sudden that steers you
out of the fucking public sector,
the fucking,
well,
that's what you're doing.
That's what you're doing right now.
What you're doing right now is doing
that exact same thing to all these
hundreds of thousands of people that are
listening to this.
That's it's the exact same thing you're
doing.
What you are saying is always been
greatest in your life.
You're,
you're introducing ideas into people's
heads that they probably never would
have come up with,
might not have come up with today.
You know,
who knows,
given the right amount of experience in
time,
anybody could probably,
you know,
that's the idea that thoughts aren't,
you're your own.
You're just tuning into them like some
sort of a it.
That's it.
Well,
that's the idea is that it?
Because I have struggled with that
because I like it.
It sounds beautiful.
It sounds kind of spooky and crazy,
but it also makes me think,
I wonder if it's just that the mechanism
for retrieving really good,
interesting creative ideas that the
method,
the mechanism for thinking,
you have to have all your resources,
all your facilitating resources,
so the ego has to be fucking completely
quiet and if the ego is not completely
quiet,
the ego is like,
I'm going to get some fucking new
clothes so I can look slick and I'm
thinking about getting news,
nose ring.
Those rings are pretty hot.
Chicks are really into that.
I wonder if my hair would be cool if it
was blond and you start really tweaking.
Your ego starts wigging out on your
shit.
Maybe I should get myself a new cadillac
chicks dig dead Shit and you start
fucking.
I'm tired of being the VP at work.
I'm going to step it up this year.
Nobody demand the fucking,
you know,
you start getting
crazy ego.
We
it like,
it cuts out all the noise.
It makes,
creates too much noise.
And the creative mind,
the,
the Zen mind,
the humble mine.
There's none of resources.
So this is a,
you know,
you use this,
this tool and this tool is to say,
oh,
I'll just pretend they're not even my
thoughts.
I'm just tuning them into the universe.
I'm so humble.
So what you're doing is with this
philosophy,
like putting it through this filter,
you've just shut your fucking nasty,
stupid ego up by saying that you're just
a vessel and you're just tuning in.
Well,
yeah.
And,
and,
and you know what man,
I'm not arguing that.
It's like either or here's how I look at
it,
or it's not either or whatever fucking
vehicle you need to use to get to the
point where the things turned off.
Use it.
If you need to conceptualize it by
thinking you're connecting with some
kind of superintelligent consciousness
that just wants the planet to be happier
because he doesn't want the planet to
dine.
It's giving its own voice there as many
people as allow it.
Whatever
vehicle would that is.
Any,
any ideology like that along the.
It's a vehicle for you managing
it's a vehicle.
You know,
it's so and so when you get in a fucking
bus to get to point a,
B or c,
it's not the bus.
It's the point that you're getting to
use the vehicle,
use whatever mechanism you have to use
to dissolve your ego to the point where
you're not going to turn into a fucking
Dick because the moment you start
claiming ownership of or whatever it is,
man,
like I think the most obvious version of
it is like super attractive.
People who act like they deserve it,
who act like they've done something for
it.
That's unfortunately how ugly that makes
It makes them like really pretty girl
say nasty shit.
You just want to say like,
do you know how fucking lucky you are?
To be as pretty as you are,
you should be like so happy all the time
to shit on what another girl looks like.
Oh my God.
It makes them ugly.
So unfortunately because of all the shit
you could talk about like when a really
hot chick shits on a girlfriend not
being so pretty like wow,
that's like damn that dude.
What is more
deadly and attractive than a super hot
girl who doesn't care that she's super
hot.
It was managed to overcome all the
fucking years of being worshiped by
people and it isn't normal and cool.
That's a.
that's a hard question,
but that girl is.
She's not going to be one of nine wives
in the cult.
What do you most to fuck?
It's smart for herself and shit.
My post apocalyptic cultural have their
place.
I love that.
Well,
you know why you can make her the high
priestess of,
they call it management,
but like the way that goes nurse,
you just got to fucking ideas.
Don't get caught up in like with the
ideas.
Continue to advance and always analyze,
observe,
look at all the people around you.
Look at all the different influences,
all the different things you can draw
from online.
Take what is useful,
analyze yourself,
you know,
it's a process where we're all a part of
this process.
We,
you and I have both seen each other
evolve.
We just don't really realize it as much
because we evolved together,
but if we went back in time 10 years ago
to when we met and then like when we
meet,
we'll use it.
It was about 10 years ago.
A little over that I think.
Really?
Yeah.
It might've been like 2001 or something.
What's it like even before that dude's
yeah,
I knew slash know.
I bet.
I bet you don't remember this.
I remember the first time that you
really.
Yes,
I was.
This was when I was a cory's assistant
at the comedy store and we,
I was sitting next to you in Newark.
I think you had.
This was right around when you just
started smoking weed or you because you
were more.
You were kind of a marijuana is starting
to become a marijuana advocate at this
time,
but it wasn't.
This was called my annoying phase now,
but it was really funny.
Yeah,
it was an annoying thing.
It was really funny because I was like,
man,
now I was sitting next to you and I at
the time I had been.
I got,
I went through this being a marijuana
advocate phase,
like,
you know,
a few,
a few years before,
but I remember sitting nice and you're
talking about weed and as a joke because
I didn't know you that well.
You didn't know me and as a dumb joke I
was like,
man,
we should be illegal and you shot me
this fucking look man.
You are,
you are allowed to make
because you thought out,
you put them up on his head.
He was all Gary Oldman him on,
you know,
I said it should be
illegal and you seem so paste.
And then corey like was like,
shut up,
shut up.
Don't say anything because we didn't
know each other and I couldn't seem like
a real asshole at the time.
But then then I don't remember that at
all.
I know.
I think you'd probably be a little
paranoid.
I think he tuned me out.
I probably would.
I don't think I would like,
like,
like got angry with you.
Don't get angry.
Probably didn't seem like the morning
Dario,
one of two things.
Either you were trying to make a joke
which would be not funny and I wouldn't
be bored
or I'd be like,
what an asshole.
Just saying that it was the former.
Then after that we started talking on
the phone and we start having
conversations like
this on the phone talking and I used to
have these fucking 45 minute phone calls
where a call them up because Dunkin was
the dude who like you'd say,
Hey,
I can work Tuesday through Thursday this
week ago.
Okay,
cool.
And then we'd know they'd get together
and create a schedule you'd called
Duncan would get your avail.
So me and Duncan just started talking on
the phone.
I don't know what started it off.
We'd have these
crazy ass 45 minute fucking while he's
working at the comedy store and every
now and be like,
oh hold on a second dude.
Sorry he,
he put me on hold.
They have to answer some other phone
call,
flag in your bed with your little swatch
baked as fuck.
Duggan was highly job every goddamn day
there.
Yeah,
there was.
It was a natural progression for me to
stay high on the job doing fear factor
as well.
It's like it all went and did like
everybody was high when they were
working and that's how you got through
work when you started working there,
you know,
I remember you.
You went through this little struggle
where he is,
you know,
you want it to be a comic,
but they didn't take you seriously while
you're still working there.
That's right.
I had to go to the vampire man in.
Anytime you fucking kill that vampire.
If you survive flowers will rain from
heaven.
I bloom.
You can get better.
Everybody can get better.
We can all of their assets and move
forward,
but you got to be positive.
So fuck.
Don't.
Don't be convinced that you have
anything figured out.
Whether it's the secret or Buddhism or
whatever the fuck it is.
Don't be convinced,
man.
Don't be given.
This world.
Might be entirely made up of
imagination.
It might be,
it might be entirely made up of
imagination.
The more time moves forward,
the more I wonder if there's a theory
and I believe that you were the first
one who introduced me to this theory as
well.
The theory that your life,
the world that you live in,
is really something that your mind has
created in.
As you get older and your body starts to
slowly deteriorates and progress towards
death in your own particular universe.
That's when the shit hits the fan and it
all goes down and you've managed to
manufacturer this idea inside your mind,
the life of your experiences in actual
real life when what it really is is just
a series of events that have been tied
together to prepare you for the next
stage of existence,
right
man,
and the more that you can let go of your
attachments to this particular life and
become the thing that is in throughout
the evolutionary cycle,
then they'll see a traumatic death.
Could you imagine that really does get
proved some day that you're and
everybody will be like,
imagination controls your fucking life.
God dammit,
I could have made a fucking awesome
life.
I just fucked up and we wired
everything.
All the Shitty luck.
Could you imagine if that was really the
case?
You believed what the fuck is?
That would be.
It would be such evil information that
people wouldn't even want it to get out,
but then you wouldn't.
That would be.
That would be a religious issue.
People might withhold that.
They found out that we are in reality
architects of our own world,
our own universe,
that each one of us is actually that
thing.
Well,
I think,
I think.
I think that if here's a,
here's a weird idea.
If there were,
imagine there is a hell and the only way
that you could keep the people on how is
making sure that they didn't realize
that,
you know,
at any second they could turn that hell
and the heaven.
You have to keep them.
You had to keep them like oblivious to
this idea.
You had realized that the thing you're
talking about,
the things that obscure the light,
so to speak,
of making people's lives great.
It's like TV.
It's the media.
Every time you turn the TV on,
it's showing you death and destruction.
When you turn on the radio,
they're talking about wars and bombs
everywhere you will look.
It's darkness,
darkness in darkness.
It's like people are really trying to
keep our consciousness focused on the
dark instead of on the light,
you know,
but the.
But if there was a global movement to
try to get people's minds to shift from
the obsession with death and all the
forms of negativity that so many people
are focused on and to turn their minds
towards a died towards the beauty and
towards friendship,
towards like healthy sex and towards
embracing each other.
Then really we,
this entire planet could transform and
to some version of heaven,
I think some something,
a form of paradise,
you know,
but there a there ultimately and
eventually,
but right now,
how long is it gonna take?
I think it's going to take it.
It's either going to be going to have to
happen right?
When it's in it,
some form of invention,
we either get an invention,
we get an alien or we get destruction.
It's quote Morrissey.
If it's not love,
it's the bomb that will bring us
together though.
It'd be awesome if you didn't quote
Morrisey.
I'm sorry,
but it's a great man.
He's great.
I've actually.
What is his real name?
Was that his real name?
Is it just going to ask me that?
I'm like every Golfer on the planet.
It's going to hate me forever if I can't
answer that right away because names.
Morrissey will be really cool quote.
If you just said his name,
not just Morrissey.
Maybe it's Ronald.
Ronald Morris.
What?
Gary Morrissey.
No,
it's more legitimate quote.
So funny how Morris he would never have
gotten name like a rapper.
He never would have gotten famous if on
his albums.
That said,
Gary,
Dude,
have you heard Gary?
Let's go.
It's kind of a mystic.
I have a mistake.
His name's Gary.
Now your mistake has been named
Charlotte getting me that.
Steven.
By the way,
Steve,
I knew someone who knew someone
who got really into yoga and changed her
name.
She insisted you call her by her new
I think there's a useful logan.
I understand that.
I think there's a usefulness to the.
I think that there's that reinvention
that's a good tool,
man,
and I understand why people do that
because if you think about your name and
where it came from with like we're not
getting named in the way people used to
get named people and people used to get
named on,
you know,
based on their actions and stuff.
They real name would come later.
We get named on what some fucking 22
year old dope decided that you're the
little pink wriggling thing that you
are.
It should be called,
you know,
where my mouth is that what you were
named after my name.
I don't know where they.
I don't know where the name came from,
but I do understand this idea of like
rebirth or the idea of like once you get
knocked off track,
why not go really deep and fucking just
rename yourself the best cult speech
have overheard of my life.
That's the way to get people to really
drink the Koolaid.
Just jump in balls first.
Come on man,
go for it.
Just get in there.
So I will take the big jump and change
your name into a crazy new name.
Your name is Duncan Bitch.
If I was joey did.
You've been.
Duncan sent you a fucking.
Now all of a sudden you want to change
governments.
Well,
I mean look at fucking Cat Stevens.
Yeah.
That's not a good example.
Crazy asshole.
Fucking murder of Salmon Rushdie.
Get outta here,
man.
Artists didn't work for prince when
Prince did it for,
um,
recording rights reasons.
Oh really?
An issue with them owning his name.
I don't think it.
I don't think it always works,
I think,
but I think sometimes I do.
I can understand the usefulness of it as
a tool.
I can understand it as a way to like
create the differentiation between
whatever the person that you were in
your earlier phases and who you've
become.
I don't think it's always good.
I think if people allow me to name them,
I will name them beautiful names that
there'll be quite pleased with.
How crazy is it?
The prince changed his name to a fucking
symbol.
What?
What an amazing move that was.
Art.
It's really an amazing,
amazing move.
I mean,
that's.
That's how you get out of a legal
contract.
You're not even a name anymore.
It's just so fucking squiggly,
crazy thing.
You know what I mean?
The,
the,
the language of contracts are so
ridiculous in the first place.
The idea that there's anything you could
ever sign away where that person owned
you and your likeness.
How the fuck can you sell that?
You don't own that anymore.
You can't use your own likeness.
Now you have to use this crazy symbol
really in signature.
Just like the signing shit.
Give up that name.
You give up the name Prince or Duncan
Trussell,
you know,
or especially if it's like a Larry the
cable guy thing where it was a name he
made up.
You know,
you get a proper.
My intellectual property.
My first name,
my first name is Charles.
My name is Charles Charles Duncan.
Trussell is now the new,
the latest name on twitter right now.
Sean.
With that,
the problem is that God is going to
confuse everybody.
Going to have a picture of you that
looks exactly like your twitter picture
and when you change and he's just going
to copy and paste it,
make his own twitter picture.
There's always some mystery.
You have an issue.
Every time you have an issue,
he's going to know a little bit more of
a fixture issue and he's going to give
you some awesome advice and you can
start really getting freaked out as to
how this is fake.
Duncan trussell really knows how to
manage the real Duncan trussell's life
and then you eventually just going to
live under the assumption that this fake
twitter account,
Charles Duncan trussell is actually the
universe giving you advice through
twitter.
Can't wait.
Charles can't wait to meet.
You're not going to get to meet them.
You're going to get to communicate with
them online.
But Charles Duncan trussell will be
given you information about what's about
to happen.
So Joseph,
are you about to start a twitter
account?
No,
I'm not doing shit.
The Universe is going to do this for us.
I love it.
Charles Duncan towards what do you have
to do is now you know,
you have various untold issues in your
life.
I'm sure we all do.
Get online and tweet them and then say,
Charles Duncan Trussell,
what should I do now?
And it's like calling them so I can't
imagine you'll come with stupid Charles
and I paid them when I was a kid.
My name's Joe.
It's like,
well I was born jets.
I started off of course Charles and then
my parents I think started just calling
me dunk and then I decided that I want
it to be called Duncan and instead of
Charles and so then that's when I became
maybe because you knew that one day you
would work with flusher,
so it wasn't even.
It's not even your middle name.
It's my middle name.
They just added it later.
No,
sometimes for some reason in the West
when we name people will give them three
names.
It won't just be a first.
Yeah,
it'll be like Joseph James Rogan,
Joseph James Rogan,
Finnegan extra.
Now summary.
The whole thing's just idiotic.
And Brian Allen Bar.
So yeah,
you just picked you.
You got to fucking pick this name,
you know,
you gotta like you can choose your
middle name or your first name.
They in fact that there is a first name
and some people,
they're so narcissistic.
They just named their kids after
themselves and that's where you're
running your jackets.
And third,
George Foreman,
George Foreman named all of his kids.
George Echos.
Now you're making a little fucking
genetic echo is named after.
You know.
It's just a terrible thing to put into
someone's mind.
Yeah.
My whole family is completely on
original.
I was Joe.
My father's name was Joe.
My grandfather's name was Joe.
My grandmother's name was really
completely unoriginal.
Just.
Yeah.
Yeah,
very well.
It was the fact I really requested a lot
of Joe.
That's what I wanted.
So I just in my life,
in my lineage,
you know,
when I was creating myself in my
imagination,
I just thought,
I want to really see what happens.
If you overdose on Joe Joe's the gate
swinging well,
who knows?
Well,
it's unoriginal names.
The Fox.
Everybody's joke.
Come on everybody.
Really?
Everyone's Brian.
You're Brian Allen.
Can you imagine if you became a standup
and you called yourself Brian Allen b?
I need to go to clubs and everybody
below.
What the fuck man?
I thought it was that black guy that
interviews comedians.
They'd all be coming soon.
If you go onto Wolfram Alpha,
you can put your name in and see how
many people right now are existing with
your name.
Well,
that's pretty rarely want to feel
insignificant or I've talked to one of
the phone that Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan.com
seemed like a nice guy.
Ex military guy,
but he wanted a lot of money for the
site.
He saw dollar bills.
It also has got his own.
He's got his own website running there
and he's been doing it for awhile.
Yeah,
he's an ex military guy.
He doesn't look like like ex military.
He looks more like a scientist or.
Well,
when they get older they look like older
men.
Weird.
Brian thinks you should have a flat top,
but a fucking knife and his teeth.
He.
It's like the opposite though.
Micro soldier.
So Duncan.
Yes sir.
We leave in the morning.
I know Chicago early.
I'm going to do the rosie o'donnell show
romantic.
I'm excited.
I'm a Rosie O'Donnell fan.
Hey,
can I say one thing real quick because
I'm fucking cool happened and I want to
announce it.
I did a south by south.
I got invited to go to south by
southwest and they offered me this
shitty deal.
I won't go into it here,
but if you want to see.
See the deal.
Look at Hitler.
Gets invited to south by southwest.
So great.
Is that just complaining because they
don't fly the comics at and it's a.
it's just a generally a bum deal and I'm
just saying this because pretty much
right after I did from that video,
I got invited to this awesome festival
that's happening happening in Austin
called the Moon Tower comedy festival
and that's happening in April and they
just like are doing the press releases
today and I just think it's so fucking
cool that they like or you know,
pay like they're showing that festivals
can pay performance,
pay airfare and put them up,
which isn't that insane and idea.
It's just normal,
but it's
beautiful.
I don't understand how anybody ever got
away with anybody working for free.
When you're making money.
I don't get the unless south by
southwest with some amazing charity that
I don't understand that they're not.
It's not a charity,
but what are you sure?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
I know it's probably all these poor.
She wishes that,
that just to be sure I have a feeling
they would have said it by now based on
the awesome videos I've been making.
The.
Yeah,
let's look up and stuff.
I said,
well,
you can't just assume like that,
right?
I'm getting my apology or start typing a
$10,000.
Right?
Charity.
That's nice.
Let's see.
Charity.
South by southwest,
it seems like they do some stuff for
charity.
You can impact charity without being
rich.
I'm sure that they do.
I'm sure it's south by southwest as
charity,
but when you ask artists to perform for
free at your festival that sponsored by
16 million different corporations,
it's a bit of a charity,
strongest memory of south by south to
south by southwest 2010 was a rooftop
party when the by southwest
partygoers spontaneously raised $300
towards the purchase of a wheelchair for
the nephew of one attendee.
The young man was paralyzed temporarily
in the family.
Could not afford a wheelchair.
That's beautiful.
That's very nice.
That's nice and all,
but still so many answers and how many
people are paying to go see south by
southwest?
It's expensive.
Ah,
look,
I go to their website.
I think the cheapest passes around 100
bucks,
but might be more than that.
Wow.
So they get everybody get everybody to
work for free,
right?
They must pay some.
No,
I think some of the like a bigger names
get paid,
but mostly after I did these videos,
mostly what I heard from people is that
the idea that Co.
Here's the concept I'll to to play south
by southwest advocate.
THe idea behind it is,
hey man,
it's just we're all having fun out here.
It's a party.
It's a chance to like hang out with a
bunch of other comics and have a good
time.
We don't invite a lot of comics out,
so it's a,
it's a,
it's an honor to get invited out and
you're going to get a chance to perform.
We'll put you up In someone's guest
bedroom,
but we can't pay you and we can't pay
for your airfare and we,
you know,
we.
You want to stay in a hotel,
you're going to have to pay for your own
hotel now.
I think that that coming from like a
festival that really was a charity,
like the make a wish foundation or
something that was solely raising money
for charity or even a startup festival.
What about just a startup festival that
seems really cool and isn't making any
money?
All that.
I totally makes it makes sense to me.
It'd be really cool,
but I think when it's coming from a
festival the size of south by southwest,
which is a giant festival,
I read that 30,000
people come through there a year and
they're asking performers to come out
for free and to pay for their own
ticket.
I think there's something in that that's
pretty fucked up,
dear southwest airlines.
If you want me to come,
I'll totally do it and I'll pay for
everything.
Thanks.
Airlines,
knucklehead.
No,
veronica rita was right.
It was fucking airline manner.
They don't even fly the comics,
so it really is.
I thought you were joking.
She told us that at dinner and we both
laughed at her and were like,
like I was like,
oh,
you're so silly.
I thought you were right.
You too.
I thought you knew.
No,
I didn't.
god damn it.
Brian,
you spread this information across the
world.
Now you've confused.
No,
no,
no.
I don't know anything about.
I don't.
I don't look at them.
I think it must be an awesome hang.
I did one thing.
What's one?
One festival.
I did summerfest in milwaukee.
It was fucking great,
man.
I loved it,
but I felt weird because I'm on stage
and I'm just doing my regular acts.
There's people with babies or holding
the babies in the crime,
like this is just fucked up,
you know?
It's just,
it's just a.
I like doing stand up in a place where
people come and see standup.
That's it.
But no,
I think.
I think festivals.
I've done festivals,
I've sometimes they're fun.
I like I did the vancouver comedy
festival that comedy festivals are
different.
I'm saying performing at a music
festival.
Yeah,
that's a little music.
Festivals are way more rowdy.
It's way this.
It's way more likely.
The people did not come to see that.
There's a big difference.
Man.
Comedy festivals are amazing.
Montreal,
montreal,
all several years.
I think I did it six years.
It was fucking great.
A whole town know montreal that
literally has been privy to these
festivals coming in every year.
So they have like this really like high
palate for comedy.
It's a fucking great place.
Do comedy.
We were supposed to go back in march,
but uh,
unfortunately the ufc had a move.
It's a march date.
They had to move the montreal date
because no champions were available and
they were going to put together a big
card for up there.
So they postponed it.
I was like,
damn,
I was really looking forward to going
back to montreal.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
my montreal,
I don't care about like,
I don't want to come across like,
I'm like,
you gotta fucking you gotta pay up if
you want me to.
It's not that at all.
It's like it's reasonable.
just acknowledge something,
you know,
they did.
Yeah,
you did.
Her pays people fly tower festival pays
people,
sasquatch pays people and people have
argued like standard
got really mad at,
you know,
what the uh,
the montreal people and started his own
thing just for spite,
you know,
they call the just for laughs.
So he would do it in town.
That it.
Yeah,
there you go.
So,
but you know when,
if you,
if you look at what they're doing,
like even if you think that they should
be paying more,
they're like,
stan hope does.
It's fucking infinitely better than
nothing.
Nothing.
Nothing's ridiculous.
Nothing,
no hotel room,
no airfare.
Well no.
They said,
here's the.
They said no hotel room,
but they say you can stay in someone's
guest bedroom.
The fuck here.
Stand over someone who live in those
days.
The other thing that the guy said to me
during these emails and the guy who
books it is a super nice guy.
I,
I started feeling guilty because he's a
really nice guy,
very friendly guy.
But he would,
he,
he couldn't acknowledge the one point
that I was making,
which is that if you're charging tickets
for people to come see performers,
you have to pay the performers
something.
It's just basic logic.
That's all.
Maybe you don't have enough to pay for
everything.
Maybe the performers,
you know,
you can only give them in a hotel and
get them out there but don't.
Because If you're making them pay for
everything,
then they're subsidizing your food.
Go though just for it to be fun in my
opinion,
like like if you're looking at ces,
the consumer electronics show or any of
these huge things,
people are usually going because it's
what they love and it's a collection and
to me I would go just because it would
be an awesome party.
It'd be awesome doing it and here's the
thing,
man,
here's the problem with that.
In my mind,
the thing that I can't get past is that
the reason it's fun and the reason
people are going,
it's because the great fucking
performers that are there,
the movies,
unquestionably it wasn't.
That was the main argument about the
comedy store.
Remember the main argument,
the ecommerce stores,
they were making it out that it was an
honor to perform at this star.
If they did that every day.
You guys are crazy because this is not.
This is just a box.
We have a microphone and you turn it on.
What you're selling here is art and the
artists are what create the art you're
selling.
Are you
selling standup comedy?
You're not.
You're not selling a spot and yeah,
it is a popular spot.
It's a popular spot because of the
artists that performed the period.
That's it.
And that's the big festivals,
the same truth.
It's the exact same truth.
And,
and festivals who are making a shitload
of money have this awesome opportunity
to make things fair.
Fair.
That's all you gotta do is make it fair.
Isn't the,
these concerts like south by southwest,
isn't this where like,
you know,
like,
like people go to go,
hey,
they were looking for people for the
next year six,
but with vancouver,
with montreal,
with,
and you can say that for any festival.
It is that right?
It is something where you for comedy
that hasn't set up man,
they get set up and then they become
law.
They'd become.
This is just how it's done and there's a
lot of them that don't make any fucking
sense and this is one of them.
The idea that you were performed with
something where people profit,
you know,
they make a profit and just pay a little
bit.
That's the thing With this guy,
the guy through my emails,
this guy charlie,
he seemed really passionate about
comedy.
He seemed like a really cool guy.
It's just if he would just,
you know,
if they would just make one small step
in the direction of being like,
you know what?
We thought about it.
We should pay airfare for the performers
to come up with something that's
sponsored by southwest.
They should be a no brainer,
share fair.
Just some discount which is drive so
much fucking business to the town.
To me,
and I'm looking at an article about nine
ways to profit from south by southwest,
but if you weren't there and they're
talking about how much figuring out how
to profit from this gathering of people,
isn't that amazing?
That's like,
would you look at human beings as some
sort of a life form and you look at just
what this article says,
nine ways to profit from south by
southwest.
Even if you weren't there,
the idea that you could be extracting
resources from some spot.
You're nowhere near there.
You don't even go there and you're just
putting out a way to profit to profit
and what is that?
What are you doing?
You're profiting.
You're pulling money out somehow or
another from someplace.
I'm not saying you're doing it
illegally.
I'm not saying you're doing anything
wrong,
but the idea that you can do that,
the idea that you're just signing checks
and sending things out,
and I'm extracting money from a
situation.
There's a lot of people in that one
spot.
When he invented that one spot and sell
them things,
it's very fucking strange.
Weird.
Really strange.
When people are weird as,
fuck,
man,
when is south by southwest in march.
I don't remember what we need to do.
You don't.
We need to do.
We need to put together an la comedy
festival.
La is one of the best places to know our
own.
I want to join anybody else's first.
Then you have to put their people on the
comedy festival.
An ice comedy festival.
I,
I'll,
I'll tell you what,
it's not a comedy festival,
but I did this.
My favorite festival that I ever did was
furries.
Yeah.
How'd you know?
I love furries.
I love dressing up like at raccoon go.
Taylor notel.
uh,
I know to tell it makes it hard for them
to grab your ass.
Yeah.
I find that some target targets in the
way basketball,
you know,
there's this place up north,
there's this place called Nevada city
and they have this film fest a lot there
and that place has the fucking deepest
hardcore hippies I've ever seen in my
life.
And there's this beautiful river.
I think it's the uma river that runs
through there and in the day you go
swimming in this river,
it's so fucking beautiful.
It's like this primordial,
wherever you jump off rocks.
It's called Nevada city,
Nevada city council,
Nevada.
It's.
They pronounce it Nevada.
It's where all the Nevada city.
Yeah.
It's like there's a,
I think that California.
Yes,
that's right.
Where you're getting into what I think,
and I may be wrong about this,
what is called the emerald triangle.
It's like,
right where you start getting more.
They grow the buds for the dispensary,
slam a jail combine fun.
Man.
That's a dangerous area too,
because they've got a lot of mexican
people that go up there to grow pot and
guys actually stay there.
It's really amazing.
I Watched a documentary on it on that
show.
God damn it,
a vanguard ever ever see that show.
I believe it's on true tv.
One of those reality tv networks.
Anyway,
these people did an investigative
journalism thing where they went into
the woods up there,
very dense woods up there,
and they found like these crazy
campsites.
So these guys had set up with this guy
who was the saint of narcotics.
Narcotic st.
Yeah.
You know,
I forget his name.
Something to narco,
you know,
and it's like,
wow,
they have a saint to watch over them
while they're growing drugs.
Why not?
Whatever,
because the thing is,
it's like if you think about what
they're doing,
nothing wrong.
Growing drugs,
nothing wrong with being a farmer.
You're just grabbing something out of
the ground.
You're not doing anything wrong.
You're not evil,
you're not bad.
But because we happen to exist at a time
period in human history or somehow
idiots have determined that certain
things that grow out of the ground or
fucking bad,
not only on certain things that have
killed anybody.
And how about these people are moving
through the night with night vision on.
They started fucking hiking at 4:00
in the morning because I had to walk
like five hours to get to these fucking
people to catch them.
You know?
So the,
these guys are hiking through the woods
at night to get farmers to catch farmer.
Go get mexican farmers catcher,
mexican,
mexican fucking god of drugs.
We kind of stopped these people.
That's all they are.
Anyone who grows pot,
you're just a farmer,
a farmer,
you know.
And it's amazing that they,
they forced these people to be fucking.
Why do they have guns?
They have guns because they have to have
guns.
They have guns because they're all the
way up here because they can't grow it
down there.
They'll get shot in the head and steal
their shit.
If you made it illegal to grow corn,
corn farmers would have fucking gun.
It's like anytime it's,
it's a,
it's a.
Yeah,
you have to defend you.
It's such a fucking.
The consciousness of this country,
this world does this,
this global entity,
this human race,
the consciousness of this human race is
altering right in front of our eyes with
the internet and the internet and
psychedelic experiences together.
That shit has changed more in this
hundred years than at any time ever.
The.
The idea
of how people feel about life on earth,
it's so different.
yeah.
It's so different than at any time and
we're riding the wave.
We're lucky.
We're so lucky.
We're were riding with or we are in a
dream that is symbolic of our own life
and we're slowly decaying and that's
when there's a great battle.
Will the shit hit the fan?
I will.
They come up with an intervention that
makes me live forever.
Tune in next week until I fucking go
head on into a semi and wake up 15 years
old going to school again.
We're going to have the
cold.
Oh,
it's the best already.
It's already.
People are drawn fucking pictures of us.
You ever seen that thing up there?
what's that?
Homeboy's name pants.
What is his name?
A formal sweatpants.
Formal sweatpants.
You can.
You could buy that joe rogan experience
a poster from him if you haven't seen
it.
It's fucking awesome.
What's his website?
Formal sweatpants.com.
Just the coolest thing.
I mean with all this stuff,
I just want you guys to all know that I
am 100 percent humbled,
blown away.
Flattered.
I can't use enough positive words to
describe how awesome it is that You
guys,
first of all,
just like the show,
but then that you make like these little
videos and little.
I mean there's so many cool videos of
rants of just you and I just you and I
just going off about stuff.
Stick man.
That,
that,
that combination is the coolest stuff
ever.
Man.
That stuff really,
really makes me happy.
Like when we went our that rant,
we had landed on Alex Jones where I was
talking about Alex Jones getting
arrested and that landed on his website.
That was intense,
man.
I was like,
fuck,
we're going to.
We're going to end up in a fucking fema
camp that's like I felt a real because I
was like,
no,
you know why we're not going to.
Because we can talk to the fucking
troops.
We can talk to the cops.
We communicate to those people and
they're not going to do with these
assholes are telling them to do.
That's ultimately a real problem with
civil unrest in this country.
The fucking genie's out of the bottle.
The cops,
the fireman.
Everybody knows that this is a fucking
mess.
Everybody knows that these people are
just.
They're just doing what you're supposed
to do when you're an american,
you're.
They're protesting some gross injustices
and they don't know exactly how to do it
and the way I've described them is that
there's a fucking.
There's a problem and their white blood
cells and they're surrounding this
problem and they don't know how to
conquer it and they don't know what to
do,
but the fact that so many people have
gravitated towards one area,
if you were looking at any other
organism and this sort of a situation
was happening,
you're like,
well,
clearly there's some sort of a disease.
There's an Illness,
there's a sickness,
there's an issue that's being addressed.
Something very,
very important is being addressed here.
Babies in the background here,
my kids are screaming,
little munchkins talking trussell monday
you're going to have some little
munchkins love some little munchkins.
Well,
you're a.
You're a good doggie daddy.
Ah,
yeah.
We got rid of our five puppies.
We have all of them.
That's awesome.
Adam all and get home to our properties.
How cute are there?
How can you not say,
you know,
you go over there and you see them.
You just gotta take a man.
Well,
yeah,
I knew that
we'd have no problem getting man.
There is nothing like the power of
fucking a young things.
It's so powerful that they can wake you
up at four in the mornings,
you know,
squeaking and you go in there and they
will do jailbreaks where they would like
get out and suddenly the house is just
flooded with chihuahua puppies that
you're trying to like bring back in and
so fun and they will always make you
like,
you can't get angry at a puppy.
It's almost impossible.
They're so god damn cute.
It's amazing how nature is sort of
engineered them nature and human beings
have engineered them to be so god damn
cute and so loving mean what's more
loving a dog man.
So funny.
That's what my sister had.
Her kid,
she did the exact same thing as your
man,
like immediately,
like who cares about the dog anymore?
Babies,
but you know what I mean?
I love playing on,
but yeah,
that's not your.
That's not a person.
Dogs and people are totally different
things,
man.
You don't even understand,
but doesn't mean I don't love my dogs.
I love a little fucking baby.
One day,
man.
Fucking three.
I think we should just both get a baby.
Don't get it.
And you'll get one week and I get the
next weekend.
Well,
I should let somebody.
We were a little bit of contest and
there'll be able to film the baby coming
out.
So that will be whoever,
whoever did the best compilation video.
We'll give them access to your wife's
vagina as the baby's coming out.
What do you say?
Well,
yeah,
it sounds great.
Sounds great.
Good.
Yeah.
Perfect.
What was the dude's name again?
Formal sweatpants.
Sweatpants doc.
And he's got the joe rogan experience
poster.
I don't know how much you selling it
for,
but it's an awesome piece of artwork.
I don't have any piece of this.
So it's all his.
I freely,
freely.
I have a poster endorsement.
You got a poster coming into.
Yeah,
they did a new desk.
Squad logo,
right?
Yeah,
I did it a top 10 bitches.
Top 10 on itunes.
Holla at your boy.
Got as high as what is sex rather than a
pow coming up in the world.
Pitches trussell this pitch up.
Bringing back squat show friday with
doug benson,
benson at the ice house.
Mike black key.
davey johnson.
Nice.
If you've never been focused,
the ice house has two rooms.
It's in pasadena.
California at the annex is very small.
It's only 85 seats with a guy like doug
benson.
That shit's gonna sell out quick.
So go to ice house.
Cc [inaudible] dot com.
Is that what it is?
Just.
Yeah,
google that.
Just for well squad.
Just go to ice house comedy and just
whatever.
google ice house comedy club and check
for stage two.
That's what you want to look for that.
so this weekend.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
I'm going to be at the arlington
drafthouse and february.
look it up.
I don't have to exactly.
It's in Texas now in Maryland.
it's called the arlington drafthouse and
I'd love to see you guys there at
arlington,
Maryland,
arlington.
Drafthouses.
What it's called,
just google it.
Arlington drafthouse is the,
uh,
the date is the second weekend in
february.
I think I have to look at my calendar,
but I just.
Is that a,
um,
a place that you do on a regular?
You've done it for the first time I've
done it.
It's in it apparently.
And uh,
it's a kind of like a movie theater and
I've heard great things about it so bad.
Who got
you that gig?
My booking guide,
apa.
Nice.
That sounds like fun.
But yeah,
I can't wait.
I did a movie theater,
like the first time I ever did
Washington dc.
They used to have that.
They'd have standup comedy and then they
will have a movie after the comedy.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it was a good gig,
man.
It was fun.
I don't remember the name of it.
Um,
so anyway,
duncan trussell be with me this friday
night at the chicago theater is almost
sold out.
There's only a,
I think there's less than 200 tickets
left.
So most tickets I've ever sold for
anything.
It's just crazy.
It's going nuts.
We have to have big giant screens.
We have to,
uh,
they have to turn on these big giant
screens to watch it.
This place is huge.
It's an enormous,
awesome place.
But um,
so that'll be this weekend,
this friday.
And then next friday we're doing the
house of blues.
Same pictures,
same lineup.
Joey diaz,
duncan trussell.
And then after both nights,
we're gonna watch some crazy shit.
We've got too crazy ufc cards hollow.
So thank you to everybody that tunes in
thanks to all the positive tWitter
messages and all the cool shit.
You know,
the the cool people outnumber the cons
by a staggering amount.
There's so many more cool people out
there that I'm connecting with because
of twitter,
because of facebook,
because of this podcast,
because of the internet.
There's so many more cool people out
there than anybody imagines.
just got to find each other.
And so we're glad you found this.
We connect,
we stay together.
We grow.
Party on party on thanks to the
flashlight,
go to joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight,
entering the code name,
rogan,
and you will get 15 percent off.
Number one,
sex toys for men.
Eventually they,
I,
I guarantee you,
I predict there'll be sponsoring the
death squad as well.
Moving up in the world that's got it.
Needs a logo.
You need a sponsor like the,
you get to talk to them.
We're gonna.
Make this happen.
It's perfect fit.
You guys have porn stars on with their
own flashlights,
you know,
just make sense.
You know,
they,
they have a design flashlight.
I have seven now.
That's like so much pocket.
Had a lot of podcasts.
The desk wide is free on itunes and it's
the only place to get the ice house
chronicles,
which is a podcast that we do live from
the ice house.
Seriously,
it is to me the coolest fucking thing
that we do.
It's so fun.
We,
it's.
We have a great time every week.
The last week we had dane cook on bert
kreischer.
Red should fear me.
Kevin christie,
brody stevens,
nick use.
If it's fucking awesome.
I mean,
you know what it is.
We have a room at the ice house and so
we have this standup show that's totally
sold out.
Packed little tiny,
intimate,
awesome room and then the comics are
rotating and going on stage from the
podcast and it's amazing.
It's the most fun and the most,
the closest you can get to like hanging
with a bunch of best friends in the
green room before we go up there and
fuck shit up.
It's like the greatest podcast of all
time.
I love the ice house chronicles.
The only way to get at those you to
subscribe desk squad,
so go to itunes,
subscribe you get death squad and get
it.
It's all free.
Of course,
it's podcasts will always be free.
Desk while will always be free.
We will not you duncan trussell though.
He'll charge you a couple of blocks and
you know what?
PAy him.
Pay him for your lavender.
Our episodes.
One dollar.
It's not much.
It's only a dollar or free.
We do one free one a week.
You can't get mad.
People get mad at hIm.
How dare you ask me for anything I've
given you free stuff you don't have to
take.
It's not like I'm saying you want
to pay,
you don't have to pay.
You do whatever you want to,
but if you want to,
there's the possibility.
I am talking for everybody asking.
I am talking with people about doing the
same thing that louis ck did.
I'm totally going to steal his idea and
try to put up my next special just
online like that just seems to make
sense.
You know,
now that everybody has a Itunes,
so many people have apple tv.
So many people have netflix and there's
so much.
I get more messages about my streaming
special from like 2005 on netflix.
I get more email about that particular
special than anything I've ever done
ever because I think more people are
seeing it through netflix.
you know,
like the,
the.
I don't know if they can get the last
one,
the talking monkey's in space,
but the netflix one they made,
they produced it.
So I get every day I get tweets about
that man.
That's the future.
The future Is louis ck showed us the
way.
So I'm going to.
I'm going to totally do what he did and
really sit that way and buying my book.
You've got a book?
Not yet.
It will be.
Alright.
You jody freaks.
Oh,
next friday.
We're at the house of blues.
Okay.
I said that already.
That's it.
Shows.
Okay,
thanks.
The flashlight thanks to [inaudible] dot
com to go to o,
n n I t.com.
What's their mysteries?
Mysteries.
The mysteries of the mind.
Pills to change your focus.
Google news,
tropics go there first 30 pills.
If you don't like it,
you get a money back guarantee.
It used to be more,
but the world's filled with cunts.
Let me know.
You could have invested $1,000,000
and probably made $30,000,000
if he would have done that in one,
but 30 pills and got sold on ebay.
Should I do that?
Yeah,
you should totally rocked my festus
started ordering shift for myself from
robin.
Dirty freaks.
We love you from the bottom of our
hearts.
Can't say it enough.
This is a.
It's hard to say goodbye.
We don't know when to do it.
I never know how to shut it off.
We're putting it out there,
putting it out there.
We're getting it from you.
Thank you very much.
We love you.
Go.